Hey guys, I'm sorry, I'm really sorry. I just got here, I'm really out of breath. What's happening? We're gonna do a show. We're gonna pod the hell out of this. You fucking... Let's do it. Are you ready to pod?
嘿，大家，对不起，我真的很抱歉。我刚到，气喘吁吁的。发生什么事了？我们要录节目了。我们要把这个播客玩个痛快。你他妈的……我们开始吧。准备好录播客了吗？
I don't know if I'm... Get the pod. Yeah, get the pod. Okay, let's get the pod. We have the cast, we're ready to pod. Okay, let me just... Get it? Guys, that's how the name came up.
我不知道我是不是……把播客拿来。对，拿来。好吧，开始录播客。我们阵容齐备，准备好录播客了。好吧，让我……拿到了吗？伙计们，名字就是这么来的。
You put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a cast, you put a let's get in the pot. We have the cast, we're ready to pod. Okay, let me just get it, guys. That's how the name came up. You put a cast inside a small area, like a pod, and then you speak. It makes a podcast. Yeah, you cast the pod. That's how it's, so anyway, I'm gonna show you how it works.
你放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个卡司，放一个我们进播客吧。我们阵容齐备，准备好录播客了。好吧，伙计们，让我拿到它。名字就是这么来的。你把卡司放进一个小空间里，就像一个豆荚，然后你说话。这就成了播客。对，你把卡司放进豆荚。事情就是这样的，总之，我要向你们展示它是怎么运作的。
Here we go. Okay. Welcome to Smirks. Smirks. Smirks. Smirks. Smirks. how it works. Here we go. Okay. Welcome to Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
我们开始吧。好的。欢迎来到 Smirks。Smirks。Smirks。Smirks。Smirks。它是怎么运作的。我们开始吧。好的。欢迎来到 Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Well, I've never seen your hair so flat. I know I said, but you just... Did you have a hat on? There it is. Are you late because you were at a flattening? Yeah, I just had to get my hair ironed
Smart。Smart。好吧，我从没见过你的头发这么平。我知道，我刚说，但你只是……你刚才戴帽子了吗？原来如此。你迟到是因为你去做头发压平了吗？对，我只是去把头发熨平了。
and I can never book this guy. Because for a while, you were crimping it, weren't you? Yeah, yeah, I was fun. I was crimping it. Yeah, do you guys remember? Scrunchies? I sure do. Yeah, scrunchies and leg warmers. Yes. I used to wear my socks as leg warmers.
而且我平时很难约到这个人。因为有一段时间，你在把头发烫成微卷，不是吗？对，对，挺好玩的。我当时在烫微卷。对，你们还记得吗？发圈？我当然记得。对，发圈和护腿套。是的。我以前把袜子当护腿套穿。
Yeah. It should be the title of your, there it is of your autobiography, Jay. Scrunchies and leg warmers. The one with a baby story. And then what, what the things called where you'd strap on weights to your wrist. Oh, oh, the, the, the, the, uh, little heavy hands walkers. Yeah. Yeah.
对。这应该作为你的自传的名字，杰伊。发圈与护腿套。那个带着育儿故事的自传。然后是什么，那些绑在手腕上的重力绑带叫什么来着？哦，哦，哦，哦，呃，那些轻量负重步行器。对。对。
I don't remember that. It's a whole Jason. I asked you this before, how in the world can you handle the heat that long outside playing golf every day? Um, I can't even handle it walking to physical therapy. You have to, uh, accept the fact that you're going to be wet and gross and sweaty and then go forward from there. I don't like getting hot when you're not supposed to get hot, you know, when you're not supposed
我不记得那个了。Jason，整件事是这样的。我以前问过你，你在外面顶着那么大太阳，天天打高尔夫，到底是怎么忍受那么长时间的高温的？嗯，我连步行去物理治疗都受不了。你必须……接受这样一个事实：你会变得湿漉漉、黏糊糊、满身大汗，然后从那个状态继续前进。我不喜欢在不该热的时候觉得热，你知道的，就是在你不应该。
to be moving wet, like if you're moving furniture. Or how about acting in a scene that's supposed to be in the winter, but you're outside and it's not shooting it in the summer and you're not supposed to be sweating your heavy clothes. And it's like being stuck in a hot car with the windows that can't roll down and someone's giving you a haircut. Like, to me, that's the biggest night America ever imagined. If the hair is 60 years skinned, you mean?
出汗的时候，比如你在搬家具。或者说，在拍一场本该是冬天的戏时演戏，但你却在户外，而且这不是在夏天拍的，你本不应该穿着厚衣服大汗淋漓。这就好像被困在一辆车窗摇不下来、热得要命的车里，还有人在给你理发。对我来说，那是美国人能想象到的最糟糕的噩梦。你是说如果头发已经稀疏了60年？
Yeah, a dry haircut in a hot car with a windows broken. Dry hair cut. But in the world made you think of that. That's so funny. Oh, I know. Hey, you know what? By the way, when I asked this, I just came back from say bars.
对，在热得要命的车里剪个干发，车窗还坏了。剪干发。但到底是什么让你想到这个的。太搞笑了。哦，我懂。嘿，你知道吗？顺便说一句，当我问这个的时候，我刚从萨伊酒吧（Saybars）回来。
I had my little tuna sushi, and I'm standing literally just five minutes ago, and I'm standing there and somebody goes, excuse me, are you online? I go, no, I'm in line. I'm not online. You know people say online. Yeah, I don't know how old this person preeled. Yeah. Yeah. This is what happens. But do you say online or in line? I was like, who says online? I say, I'm, oh, standing in line. If I'm waiting to buy groceries, I'm in line.
我吃了点金枪鱼寿司，我当时就站在那儿，字面意思，就在五分钟前，我站在那儿，有人走过来问：不好意思，你在线上（online）吗？我说，不，我在排队（in line）。我不在线上。你知道有人会说online。对，我不知道这人多大岁数。对。对。事情就是这样。但你会说online还是in line？我当时想，谁会说online啊？我说，我，哦，站在队里。如果我在等买杂货，我就是在排队。
Yes, exactly. You know, logging into my hot line. If I'm waiting to buy groceries, I'm in line. Yes, exactly. You know, logging into my hotmail account, I'm online. Online, exactly. Yeah, yeah. So, and in Canada, they say lineup. You say there's a huge lineup. Instead of a huge lineup. At the grocery store?
是的，没错。你知道的，登录我的热线（hot line）账户。如果我在等买杂货，我就是在排队。是的，没错。你知道的，登录我的hotmail账户，我是在线上（online）。在线上，完全正确。对，对。所以，在加拿大，他们说lineup（排队）。你会说那里有一个巨大的lineup。而不是huge lineup。在杂货店里？
Yeah, they'll say, yeah, there's a huge lineup. And they'll say lineup up, I know. So, whatever, I don't know. I didn't understand online. So maybe some people get to say, like, are you on line up? OK. Maybe not. Well, we've lost all of our listeners before the guest.
对，他们会说，对，有一个巨大的lineup。他们会说lineup up，我懂。所以，管他呢，我不知道。我不懂online。所以也许有些人会说，嘿，你在lineup上吗？好吧。也许不是。好吧，我们在嘉宾来之前已经把听众都得罪光了。
All right, let's get to it. You know how I love tough cookies. Today I got a tough cookie who's super soft and squishy on the inside full of love. I love this person. She's a super smarty. She's known for having her finger in the pulse of what's next in love this person. She's a super smarty. She's known for having her finger in the pulse of what's next in the tech world.
好了，我们言归正传。你知道我有多喜欢硬汉。今天我请来了一块“硬汉”，不过她内心超级柔软温和，充满了爱。我超爱这个人。她是个超级聪明的人。她以对科技界最新趋势了如指掌而闻名。
She's also a podcast pioneer. I've actually heard her take credit for this one. Oh my God. I love this one. I'm really curious about this woman. She's been a friend for quite a while. Most interviews she does in Aviator Sunglasses. Let's see if she has been a month today.
她也是播客先驱。我甚至听过她把这个功劳揽到自己身上。噢天哪。我太喜欢这个了。我真的对这位女士很好奇。她做我的朋友已经有一段时间了。她接受采访时大多戴着飞行员太阳镜。让我们看看她今天是不是这样。
It's the host of on with Cara Swisher and Coast of the Pivot Podcast, my brilliant friend. Oh, Cara Swisher. Hi. Thank you so much Podcast, my brilliant friend. Oh, Cara Swisher. Thank you so much for she had to suffer. You had to suffer through that. That was exciting. The online thing. Say, well, oh, there's a Biden's.
她就是《On with Cara Swisher》的主持人和《Pivot》播客的主播，我才华横溢的朋友。哦，卡拉·斯韦瑟（Cara Swisher）。嗨。非常感谢播客，我才华横溢的朋友。哦，卡拉·斯韦瑟。非常感谢她不得不受罪。你不得不经历那些。太刺激了。那个online的事情。等等，好吧，哦，有拜登的。
You put him on the Biden's on. I was before Biden. Joe, do you hear that? Yeah, I'm sure he's listening. What didn't I say, Will, you you clown me during the interview with Biden? And I didn't I call his wife by her first name? Yeah, you should. Right.
你把他弄上了，拜登上了。我在拜登之前。乔，你听到那个了吗？对，我确信他在听。我说了什么吗，威尔，你在采访拜登时嘲笑我？我是不是叫了他妻子的名字？对，你应该的。对吧。
It's Dr. Biden, it's Dr. Biden. Yeah, you said, yeah, you said she's a chill. Are we saying, are we saying Joe and Jill? Yeah, like I'm boys with Joe and Jill. And Cara, thank you so much for saying yes, to the Roojohn for canceling on you on the road. I know, I heard it was in your HBO thing. I haven't watched that yet, but I heard it.
那是拜登博士，那是拜登博士。对，你说了，对，你说她是吉尔。我们在说，我们在说乔和吉尔吗？对，就像我和乔和吉尔是铁子一样。卡拉，非常感谢你答应来，虽然罗恩（Roo）放了你的鸽子。我知道，我听说那是你在HBO的节目里的事。我还没看那个，但我听说了。
You should be full protest. It's fine, it's fine. I am, who did you replace with, that Damon or something like that? That Damon, someone becoming Jackie A. Yeah, whose career is over now. It's over out of the business. Out of the high-mer thing.
你应该全力抗议的。没关系，没关系。我是，你找谁替代的，达蒙还是别的什么？达蒙，某人变成了杰基·A。对，那个现在事业已经完蛋的人。离开这一行了。退出了高管圈子。
It was a waste. It's a disaster for of the business. I'm a high-mer thing. It was a waste. It's a disaster for him. Yeah. Yeah. So, yeah. No, we had a problem. It's okay. I could give a fuck, but okay. No. That's what Sean said. You'd say. Yeah. Yeah.
太浪费了。对他来说是一场灾难。离开这一行了。高管圈子。太浪费了。对他来说是一场灾难。对。对。所以，对。不，我们遇到过问题。没关系。我才他妈不在乎呢，不过好吧。不。肖恩就是这么说的。你会说的。对。对。
I was going to ask you if you were nervous to be on a day, but clearly you're not, you know, the air. I'm like 10 podcasts in this morning, and I'm talking to a Chris Christie interview, so I'm really fine. Wait, you just, did you interview talking for a Chris Christie interview. So I'm really fine. Wait, you just did you interview Chris? No, it's Namunday, Monday or Tuesday. Something like that.
我正要问你上节目紧不紧张，但显然你不紧张，你知道，空气。我今天早上已经录了大约10个播客了，我还要跟克里斯·克里斯蒂（Chris Christie）做个采访，所以我真的很好。等等，你刚才，你采访了谈论克里斯·克里斯蒂的采访。所以我真的很好。等等，你刚刚，你采访了克里斯吗？不，是周一还是周二。差不多吧。
How do you prep for a Chris Christie interview? Now, I'm a, I'm a die hard Democrat, but I don't mind listening to him speak sometimes. He really can frame a, a, a, a position. Yeah. Yeah. When he's attacking people in his own party, he's, you know, he, it's like a symphony. a. Yeah. When he's attacking, when he's attacking people in his own party, he's, you know, he, it's like a symphony. Yeah.
你怎么为克里斯·克里斯蒂的采访做准备？我是个坚定的民主党人，但我不介意有时听他讲话。他确实很擅长阐述一个立场。对。对。当他在攻击自己党内的人时，你知道，他，这就像是一场交响乐。对。当他在攻击，当他在攻击自己党内的人时，你知道，他，这就像是一场交响乐。对。
Yeah. Well, you know, that's the issue is that do you forgive him for his trespasses kind of thing? And I think a lot of people don't want to because he really was down with Trump for a very long time until Trump tried to kill him with COVID. And so like what happened like that kind of thing. And of course, there's the bridge gate. Yeah. Obviously, it was real. You know, but he's a great, he was
好吧，你知道，问题在于你是否原谅他的过失之类的事情。我想很多人都不愿意，因为他在很长一段时间里确实和特朗普混在一起，直到特朗普用新冠病毒差点把他害死。所以事情就是这样发展的。当然，还有门桥丑闻（Bridgegate）。对。显然，那是真的。你知道，但他是个伟大的，他曾是
a prosecutor in New Jersey. Right. And there's also the close beach gate as well. The beach gate, that was a nice thing. Do you remember that one? No. What happened there? I remember, you want to tell it, you tell it.
新泽西州的检察官。没错。还有关闭海滩丑闻（beach gate）。海滩丑闻，那挺有意思的。你还记得那个吗？不。发生什么事了？我记得，你想讲你就讲。
Yeah, he was on a beach by himself, they're all these pictures. And then it became an internet meme, which was my favorite part of it. Because, and here's why, it's because he was using the New Jersey governor's summer beach house, right? They have one. And he had closed as governor. He had closed all the state beaches for various reasons. I think for maybe because it was COVID.
对，他独自一人在一个海滩上，到处都是照片。然后它变成了互联网表情包，这是我最喜欢的部分。因为，原因就在于：他当时在使用新泽西州长的夏季海滩官邸，对吧？他们有一个。作为州长，他关闭了。出于各种原因，他关闭了所有的州立海滩。我想可能是因为新冠。
Yeah. Was it COVID? Yeah. It was trash the virus like a two-foot swell. Like sand. But then he was out on the beach by himself. And that was the first time, that was the first time we ever saw a politician be a hypocrite. It was astonishing. It was astonishing.
对。是新冠吗？对。把病毒踩在脚下，就像两英尺高的海浪一样。就像沙子一样。但随后他独自一人出现在海滩上。那是第一次，那是我们第一次看到一个政客如此虚伪。太令人震惊了。太令人震惊了。
And then people started. But it's called the Jersey Shore. Just remember, it's the shore. We know there's no beach in Jersey. It's a Jersey shore. It's a Jersey shore. Sure, sure, sure. That's fair enough. But he did wash up there. I mean, there were a lot of obviously comparisons that were made to, yeah, whales. And yeah, I was waiting for someone to take this, the softball. Yeah. Anyway, anyway, we didn't. We didn't. No, you brushed against it. You did not hit the ball. No, it was just a foul. Just a, just a, just a, you had, you just do podcasts after podcasts. Yeah, I do. I do. And how do you, do you still love to do it?
然后人们开始。但它叫泽西海岸（Jersey Shore）。记住，是海岸。我们知道泽西没有海滩。那是泽西海岸。那是泽西海岸。海岸，海岸，海岸。这倒也是。但他确实被冲到那里去了。我的意思是，显然有很多比较，比如和鲸鱼相比。是的，我一直在等有人接这个软球。对，总之，总之，我们没接。我们没接。不，你擦边而过了。你根本没击中球。不，只是个界外球。只是，只是，只是，你就是一个接一个地录播客。对，我录。我录。那你，你还热爱做这件事吗？
I love it. I started about 10 years ago. Are you not podcasted out? No, I think you guys are doing great. Are you going to get into radio eventually? What's going on? No, no, no. I actually know.
我很热爱。我大约10年前开始的。你没有对播客感到厌倦吗？不，我觉得你们做得很好。你最终会涉足广播吗？怎么回事？不，不，不。其实我知道。
No, no, it's a dying medium. No, I actually went to Bob Pittman who runs I Heart Radio when I had this idea. And he sat me down. I've known him since he covered AOL. I wrote a couple books on AOL. He was one of the characters in the book. And he goes, Cara, podcasting is a dead end.
不，不，这是个日渐没落的媒介。不，其实我有这个想法时，我去找了管理 iHeart Radio 的鲍勃·皮特曼（Bob Pittman）。他把我拉坐下来。自从他报道美国在线（AOL）以来我就认识他了。我写过几本关于AOL的书。他是书中的人物之一。他对我说：“卡拉，播客是个死胡同。”
You shouldn't do it. And I was like, oh, yeah, oh, Bob Pitt. Okay, Bob, you should do radio. But then you know, you know, he's straight into Matt with John Sykes. Johnny Sykes. Johnny Sykes told me you're wrong, Bob. Yeah, yeah, yeah, indeed.
“你不该做这个。”然后我想，哦，好吧，哦，鲍勃·皮特。好吧，鲍勃，你应该去做广播。但后来你知道，你知道，他直接和约翰·赛克斯（John Sykes）合作了。强尼·赛克斯。强尼·赛克斯告诉我：“你错了，鲍勃。”对，对，对，确实如此。
But anyway, so I loved it. I loved doing it. And I love doing all the different ones we do. Well, for my sister, who may not know what you do in the brilliance that you are, you have been reporting on the tech industry since the early 90s. You're like one of the first people to ever kind of dive in with the big CEOs of all of these companies and get into their heads and interview them. And you've spoken to all of them, Bezos, Elon Musk, like just everybody.
但不管怎样，我喜欢它。我喜欢做这个。我喜欢我们做的所有不同类型的节目。好吧，为了我的姐姐，她可能不知道你的工作以及你的惊人才华，你从90年代初就开始报道科技行业了。你就像是第一批深入接触所有这些公司的大型CEO、走进他们的脑海并采访他们的人。你采访过他们所有人，贝佐斯、埃隆·马斯克，几乎所有人。
And you're one of the most brilliant, I think people I've ever met and known and been friends with. Thank you, sir. And I love it. You're like, you're free. Like, if I don't have to read a book, thanks to our friendship. Yeah. Because it's like, I text you.
而且我认为你是我这辈子见过、认识并与之交友的最聪明的人之一。谢谢你，先生。我太喜欢了。你就像是，你是自由的。比如，多亏了我们的友谊，我都不用读书了。对。因为我会给你发信息。
I'm like, what does this mean? You're like, do this. Don't do that. And it's fantastic. Yes, I'm your, I'm your I'm your circuit city service to you like your super valuable asset to all of us dummies out here in the world Yeah, you seem dumb you seem done Jason We when I was cramped pretty one you're the pretty one yeah, well you know actually will with the gun show that you're just Yeah, what's you just want to create. You know, actually will with the gun show that you were just doing. Right. Yeah.
我会问：“这是什么意思？”你会说：“这样做。别那样做。”这太棒了。是的，我是你的，我是你的，我是你的电路城（Circuit City）客服，就像是你这个世界上的所有笨蛋们的超有价值资产。对，你看起来很笨，你看起来很笨，Jason。当我们烫着微卷的时候……你是那个长得好看的，对吧。好吧，你知道，威尔，带着你刚才展示的肌肉。对。怎么回事？你知道的，其实威尔，带着你刚才展示的肌肉。没错。对。
What's going on there? Right. But what an asset we have in you. It's a show that's been running for a long time. And your podcast, the way that you explain and break down things for all of us, that's so complicated. Thank you.
那里怎么回事？没错。但拥有你真是我们的宝贵财富。这是一个已经做了很久的节目。你的播客，你向我们解释和拆解那些极其复杂事物的方式，太棒了。谢谢。
I'm trying to figure out and navigate all this stuff. Yes, I want to ask you about that. I want to ask you about that. Yeah, AI, I want to know. But a front of mind right now, me are two things both Musk related one Current status on the cage match and also why the switching Why are we switching from the bird to the X? Oh, and I'm sorry if there are articles out there. They explain all this, but I'm not a reader
我一直在试图弄清楚并应付所有这些事情。是的，我想问你这个。我想问你这个。是的，关于AI，我想知道。但眼下我最关心的是两件事，都和马斯克有关：一个是铁笼格赛的现状，另一个是为什么我们要把小鸟换成X？哦，如果外面有文章解释了这一切，我深表歉意，但我不是个爱阅读的人。
Well, I think the X one is this is your brain on drugs, but um, let's uh, let's start with uh Well, you know, it's interesting because I knew Elon when he was and he was head of failed company, actually. One of his early companies he got kicked out of, he made a couple million dollars, but was sort of washed up pretty early on and then started a company called X.com, which was a competitor to PayPal. They hated each other, I covered them. They had this sort of, you know, manned, not manned boy-fest arguments going on.
好吧，我觉得关于那个“X”的换标，简直就是“吸毒后的大脑”，不过，让我们……让我们从……好吧，你知道，这很有趣，因为我认识埃隆的时候，他当时是……其实是一家失败公司的负责人。他早期被踢出局的公司之一，让他赚了几百万万美元，但很早就有些江郎才尽了，然后创办了一家名为X.com的公司，这是PayPal的竞争对手。他们恨死对方了，我当时报道过他们。他们之间发生了一场……那种带有男孩气的争论。
And then they merged and luckily sold to eBay and made their fortunes. And Elon, you know, had a lot of mistakes before that and actually was really intriguing and interesting person because the rest of them went off and did kind of stupid things. And Elon started doing space, Tesla, really cool stuff. And I spent a lot of time with him, and he's changed rather drastically in the last. Let me ask you this, because you would, obviously you know this.
然后他们合并了，幸运的是卖给了eBay，赚取了巨额财富。埃隆在那之前有很多失误，实际上是一个非常迷人和有趣的人，因为其他人后来都去做了一些比较蠢的事情。而埃隆开始做太空、特斯拉，那些非常酷的事情。我花了很多时间跟他在一起，而在过去的这段时间里，他发生了相当戏剧性的变化。我问你这个，因为你，显然你知道这些。
So yeah, I remember when X and PayPal merged, and he tried to bring X on, he tried to drag that over, and he tried to get rid of PayPal, and there was a big, there was a legal thing there with Peter Tilly, he had a big argument about that. He got zeroed out. He got zeroed out and and it seems like To me He's obviously a
所以，是的，我记得当X和PayPal合并时，他试图把X带进来，他试图把那个强加进来，并试图摆脱PayPal，当时那里有一场巨大的法律纠纷，和彼得·蒂尔（Peter Thiel），他们对此有激烈的争论。他被清零了。他被清零了，而且在我看来，他显然是一个
fairly clever guy and Elon Musk It does it does appear that he Missled people about his education. It seems like he did not graduate with any degrees from any of these places that he claims he drew
相当聪明的人，而埃隆·马斯克，看起来他确实在学历上误导了别人。看起来他并没有从他声称自己毕业的那些地方获得任何学位。
from including Queens in Canada. And he doesn't have all these high fluten degrees that he calls himself a physicist and all this kind of shit. Yeah, he calls himself a lot of things. So it's bullshit. So what's happening is, and Jason, this would make you crazy because he's actually just lying about it.
包括加拿大的女王大学（Queens）。他根本没有那些高大上的学位，却自称是物理学家之类的鬼话。对，他自称是很多东西。所以这都是胡扯。所以发生的情况是，Jason，这会把你气疯，因为他实际上就是在撒谎。
And nobody just says he's just lying, right? Well, you know, look, let's be clear. He's had, look, what's interesting is to meet these people before they had money very, you know, and they change rather drastically when some of them do, some of them don't. I mean, Tim Cook is a lovely guy, Brian Chesky, Ronser, B&B, couldn't be nicer. But some people get warped really beyond repair after they get so much money. And being the world's richest man, and then this concept of yourself. And, you know, there's a book coming out by Walter Isaacson that's going to talk about his early life, but his father was quite brutal to him. He was bullied as a kid. That doesn't mean every bully becomes this.
而没有人直接说他就是在撒谎，对吧？好吧，你知道，听着，我们得弄清楚。他有，听着，有趣的是在这些人有钱之前认识他们，你知道的，当他们有些发迹之后，有些人的变化相当剧烈，有些则没有。我是说，蒂姆·库克（Tim Cook）是个可爱的人，布莱恩·切斯基（Brian Chesky），Airbnb的创始人，人好得不得了。但有些人一旦有了那么多钱，心灵就会扭曲到无法修复的地步。成为世界首富，以及伴随而来的自我膨胀。而且，沃尔特·艾萨克森（Walter Isaacson）即将出版一本关于他早年生活的书，但他的父亲对他非常残酷。他小时候被霸凌过。这并不意味着每一个霸凌受害者都会变成这样。
But yeah, I, but I'm saying he is a self-made person in terms of the stuff he's done as a business person. I'm sure, sure, however, at the same time, he's also, so not only is he lied about that, but he's also misled people about he didn't invent Tesla, he didn't invent any of these things. Yes. And I think that he's obviously quite a shrewd businessman. That's what he is best at, but he tries to sell himself as the inventor when really he's a good businessman.
但，是的，我，但我的意思是，作为一个商人的所作所为，他是一个白手起家的人。当然，当然，然而与此同时，他也是，不仅在学历上撒过谎，他还在别的事上误导过别人，比如他并没有发明特斯拉，他也没有发明这些东西中的任何一个。是的。而且我认为他显然是一个相当精明的商人。这才是他最擅长的，但他试图把自己包装成发明家，而实际上他只是个优秀的商人。
And it's okay to be a good businessman, but he doesn't get his, he wants the credit for being a big brand. A tech visionary. I mean, I think he sees himself as the iron man, that guy, I think that's who Robert Doney Jr.'s role there. But he does have technical, logical chops, there's no quite,
当一个优秀的商人是可以的，但他得不到他想要的，他想要的是作为一个伟大品牌的功劳。一个科技远见者。我的意思是，我觉得他把自己看作是钢铁侠那种人，我觉得那是小罗伯特·唐尼扮演的那个角色。但他确实有技术和逻辑方面的硬实力，毫无疑问，
you couldn't, you couldn't think of this long. But you're right, he didn't start Tesla, you know, he bought companies, he's buying Twitter, he's turned out to be very bad at media. Yeah. And but he is, let me just say, he's, he is quite brilliant in terms of business. And he also, you could say that about Steve Jobs didn't have real technical chops. It was others, Steve was the act and others, but he knew how to build a business. Yes. And that was critical. That was critical. I agree. And by the way, I'm not suggesting that he's not too hard. I can't believe I'm defending Elon right now.
你不可能随随便便想出这么长远的……但你是对的，他没有创立特斯拉，你知道的，他是收购了公司，现在他在收购推特，结果证明他在媒体运营方面非常糟糕。是的。但是，让我直说吧，在商业方面他相当才华横溢。而且你也可以这么说，史蒂夫·乔布斯也没有真正的技术硬实力。是其他人，史蒂夫是那个表演者，而其他人负责技术，但他知道如何建立一家公司。是的。这至关重要。这至关重要。我同意。顺便说一句，我不是在暗示他不够拼。我简直不敢相信我刚才在为埃隆辩护。
No, I know I can't even either. That's amazing. He's a super showed right now. Well, this is your fifth podcast of the day. The one thing that sounds pretty interesting that he's, that, well, there's a few things he's doing that's kind of interesting, but this, um, Starlink.
不，我知道，我也不敢相信。太惊人了。他现在真是个超级精明的家伙。好吧，这是你今天的第五个播客。听起来有一件事挺有意思的，他正在做，好吧，他有几件事做得挺有意思的，但这个，星链（Starlink）。
Is it, is it, is Neuralink or, or? No, Neuralink is, is, is a brain, just a chip in your brain. Right, now, yeah, is that as kind of real as they want it to sound? And if so, what is it, no? It's the idea, sort of like, you know, you watch the Matrix, you put something in your brain
是，是脑机接口（Neuralink），还是？不，Neuralink是，是关于大脑的，就是在你大脑里植入芯片。好吧，现在，是的，这像他们吹嘘的那样真实吗？如果是的话，到底是什么，不是吗？它的理念有点像，你知道的，你看过《黑客帝国》，你在大脑里植入某种东西。
and it gives you, you know, you immediately can do karate or whatever. It's like a port that you can like put a hotline drive into. Sean, if you learned karate in a port that you can like put a hot dog in. Shung, if you learned karate in a man or something. Karate, Karate. What are we talking about? What are we talking about?
然后它就能让你，你知道的，立刻学会空手道什么的。这就像是一个接口，你可以把热狗盘连上去。顺便说一句，如果通过一个接口能学会空手道……空手道，空手道。我们在说什么？我们在说什么？
It's a pill. No, it's a, it's a, it's a, it's technology that you put. It's, there are some ideas that it could help people who, who cannot walk and things like that. Eventually, we'll have that. Yes. And so Elon's idea, and this was really interesting when I interviewed him once, was that AI was, he's been obsessed about AI for a long, long time and very worried about it.
那是一颗药丸。不，这是一种，这是一种，这是一种你植入的技术。有些观点认为它能帮助那些无法行走的人之类的人。最终，我们会实现这一点的。是的。所以埃隆的想法——当我某次采访他时，这真的很有趣——是人工智能，他长期以来一直对人工智能痴迷，并且非常担忧。
And in fact, he was early investor in a lot of stuff. He's quite pressuring about a lot of trends. And so he thought that at first that AI was going to kill us essentially, that, you know, that same old trope. And then later, he decided it was gonna treat us like house cats, like that we were, okay, we'll just feed you. Then he moved on to Ant Hills, which was interesting.
事实上，他是很多早期项目的投资者。他对很多趋势都有很强的远见。所以他一开始认为人工智能本质上会杀死我们，你知道的，也就是老掉牙的科幻桥段。然后后来，他决定人工智能会像对待家猫一样对待我们，也就是，好吧，我们只管喂饱你们。接着他又改成了蚂蚁丘的说法，这很有趣。
So that, like, when we're building a highway and we cover, we did store an Ant Hill, we don't know it, we don't want to, but it's in our way, but we don't think, I shall kill the ants today. So, he thought that we should need more throughput in our brains to keep up with AI. That was the inspiration. But then he also has Starlink, which is different, which is doing satellites.
也就是说，当我们建造一条高速公路并从一个蚂蚁丘上压过去时，我们甚至不知道，也不想去注意，但这正好挡了我们的路，但我们不会想：我主要今天踩死这些蚂蚁。所以，他认为我们需要提高大脑的吞吐量，才能跟上人工智能的步伐。这就是灵感来源。但同时他还有星链，那是另一回事，那是做卫星的。
What's Starlink? Which is Internet. It's satellite Internet. It's being used in Ukraine quite actively for battlefield communication. As opposed to fiber optics? Yeah, it's a satellite. And nobody is as far along as he is. Same thing with SpaceX. Why is that more advantageous than fiberlink or fiber optics?
什么是星链？也就是互联网。它是卫星互联网。它目前在乌克兰被非常活跃地用于战场通信。而不是光纤？对，是卫星。目前没有任何人的进度能赶上他。SpaceX也是如此。为什么这比光纤或光纤链路更有优势？
Because it's in the air. In places where they don't have the cable blade. You can't drag the cable to where you live in Los Angeles. It's all cable. It's all cable. You have cable right up your ass. And we will be right back. Thanks to good RX for supporting Smarlas. Are you ready for this year's cold and flu season? Whether you're looking for savings on your flu vaccine or advice on staying healthy, GoodRx is here to help. Best of all, GoodRx is completely free, easy to use,
因为它在空中。在那些没有铺设电缆的地方。你不可能把电缆拉到你住在洛杉矶的家门口。到处都是电缆。到处都是电缆。你的屁股里都插着电缆。我们马上回来。感谢 GoodRx 对 SmarLess 的支持。你准备好迎接今年的流感季节了吗？无论你是想在流感疫苗上省钱，还是想寻找保持健康的建议，GoodRx 都能为你提供帮助。最棒的是，GoodRx 完全免费、易于使用，
and can help save you up to 80% on all your prescriptions. All you need to do is search for your medication on the GoodRx website or app and show your GoodRx coupon at the pharmacy. It's that easy. GoodRx is accepted at all major pharmacies in your neighborhood, including CVS, Kroger, Walgreens, Rite Aid, Vons, Walmart, Sam's Club, and many more. And remember, GoodRx works whether you have insurance or not. Even if you have insurance, goodRx may beat your copay price.
并且可以帮你节省高达 80% 的处方药费用。你只需要在 GoodRx 网站或应用上搜索你的药物，然后在药房出示你的 GoodRx 优惠券即可。就是这么简单。GoodRx 被你家附近的所有主要药房接受，包括 CVS、Kroger、Walgreens、Rite Aid、Vons、Walmart、Sam's Club 等等。请记住，无论你是否有保险，GoodRx 都适用。即使你有保险，GoodRx 的价格也可能比你的自付额（copay）更划算。
Look, do you like to save money? Because if you like to save money, continue listening to me. If you're one of those people who's like, no, I don't want to save money, I'd rather pay full price. And if you're going to tell me that I could save up to 8% on my prescriptions, don't talk to me. Fine, do that. Give these people all your money.
听着，你喜欢省钱吗？因为如果你喜欢省钱，就继续听我说。如果你是那种说“不，我不想省钱，我宁愿付全价”的人。如果你要告诉我买处方药能省下高达 8% 的费用，那就别跟我谈。好吧，随你便。把你们的钱全都给这些人吧。
But if you're like me and you're approaching this season and you're thinking, how can I save a few bucks? Guess what? GoodRx is the way to go. And I know that it works because I know personally three people who I've talked to about it when I told them that GoodRx was a supporter of SmartLess and they told me how great it was. So, knowing all that, this cold and flu season, stay prepared with GoodRx.
但如果你和我一样，正迎来这个季节，并在想：我怎么才能省下几块钱呢？你猜怎么着？GoodRx 就是最佳选择。我知道它管用，因为我个人认识三个人，当我告诉他们 GoodRx 是 SmartLess 的赞助商时，我跟他们聊过，他们都告诉我这东西有多棒。所以，了解了这些，在这个流感季节，带上 GoodRx 做 好准备。
Go to goodRx.com slash SmartLess. That's goodRx.com slash SmartLess. GoodRx is not insurance. SmartLess is supported by Zip Recruiter. Hey, did you know that if you're an employer who's hiring, the average cost per hire is $4,700. If you're investing that much money into each new hire, you want to get it right.
访问 goodRx.com 斜杠 SmartLess。也就是 goodRx.com 斜杠 SmartLess。GoodRx 不是保险。SmartLess 获得 ZipRecruiter 的支持。嘿，你知道吗，如果你是一个正在招聘的雇主，每个新员工的平均招聘成本是 4,700 美元。如果你在每个新员工身上投入了这么多钱，你肯定希望招对人。
So what's the most effective way to find the best people for your roles? Zippercrooter. See for yourself right now you can try it for free at zippercrooter.com slash smartless and experience the value zippercrooter brings to hiring. Zippercrooter gives you the power to zero in on top talent. Got your eye on an excellent candidate? Zippercrooter lets you reach out to them. You can easily send candidates you're really interested in a personal invite to apply
那么，为你的岗位找到最优秀人才的最有效方法是什么？ZipRecruiter。现在就亲自去看看吧，你可以在 ziprecruiter.com 斜杠 smartless 上免费试用，并体验 ZipRecruiter 为招聘带来的价值。ZipRecruiter 赋予你精准锁定顶级人才的能力。看中了一个优秀的候选人？ZipRecruiter 允许你主动联系他们。你可以轻松地向你真正感兴趣的候选人发送个人申请邀请，
to help your job stand out amongst the competition. It's simple, Zip Recuder helps you get hiring right. Four out of five employers who post on Zip Recuder get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself! Go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recuder for free before you commit ziprecruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's zippercruder.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S zippercruder, the smartest way to hire.
帮助你的职位在竞争中脱颖而出。很简单，ZipRecruiter 帮你轻松搞定招聘。在 ZipRecruiter 上发布职位的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天内就能获得优质候选人。亲自来看看吧！访问这个独家网址，在做出承诺之前免费试用 ZipRecruiter：ziprecruiter.com 斜杠 smartless。再次强调，网址是 ziprecruiter.com 斜杠 S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S，ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。
Thanks to Grammarly for their support. You know how hard writing can be, right? I'm horrible at it and I want my grammar to be good or because it's better than most. Even writing emails are hard for me. I just can't do it. So when it comes to writing, Grammarly is there to support you from beginning to end. For over 10 years, Grammarly has been powered by AI technology, you can trust and rely on to help you across all the places where you write the most.
感谢 Grammarly 对本节目的支持。你知道写作有多难，对吧？我在这方面烂透了，我希望我的语法好一点，或者至少比大多数人好。甚至写电子邮件对我都很难。我就是做不来。所以说到写作，Grammarly 从头到尾都在支持你。十多年来，Grammarly 一直由人工智能技术驱动，你可以信任并依赖它来协助你处理所有需要大量写作的场景。
And now, Grammarly helps you do even more. With one click, you can easily brainstorm, rewrite, and reply quickly with suggestions based on your context and goals. So you can improve productivity for you and your teams. Need to get through your emails quicker like me. Grammarly can help you summarize your emails and provide suggestions on how to reply in seconds.
现在，Grammarly 可以帮你做更多事情。只需点击一下，你就可以根据你的语境和目标获得建议，轻松集思广益、重写和快速回复。从而提高你和团队的工作效率。想像我一样更快地处理电子邮件吗？Grammarly 可以帮你在几秒钟内总结电子邮件并提供回复建议。
If you guys saw my text between Scottie and I, you would laugh because I don't even finish sentences. I barely get, and you know when they make suggestions about you want to try this word, or maybe you're right when I just get right past it because I'm in a hurry. And so Scottie's asked me to start using Grammarly because he's beyond annoyed with me and my lack of abilities. You'll be amazed at what you can do with Grammarly. Go to Grammarly.com slash go to download for free today. That's g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y.com slash go. All right, back to the show. All of these tech companies that care that you,
如果你看过我和斯科蒂（Scottie）之间的短信，你一定会笑，因为我甚至连句子都写不完整。我勉强能……你知道当他们提出建议，比如你想试试这个词，或者也许你对了，而我直接就忽略了，因为我很赶时间。所以斯科蒂要求我开始使用 Grammarly，因为他对我以及我那糟糕的能力简直烦透了。你会对 Grammarly 的强大功能感到惊叹。访问 Grammarly.com 斜杠 go，今天就免费下载。也就是 g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y.com 斜杠 go。好的，回到节目中。所有这些科技公司，卡拉，你……
we put my, wait, I wanna stay on A.I. first, cause then I wanna ask that last question. So, so. Yeah, yeah, I will decide what you're gonna stay on. What arm you thinking about? I'm sorry, Sean. I'm fascinated just by technology. I just love it.
我们要聊我的……等等，我想先留在人工智能（AI）这个话题上，因为我接下来想问最后一个问题。所以，所以。对，对，我会决定我们要聊什么。你在想哪方面？对不起，肖恩。我只是对技术着迷。我就是爱它。
And you know, Scotty, my husband loves, you know, lives for. Yeah. We can't just have a light switch. It's gotta be, you know, this button turns this and I can do it for you know Scotty. My husband loves, you know, lives for. Yeah. We can't just have a light switch. It's gotta be, you know, this button turns this and I can do it for my phone or whatever. But now, and then like last November, it was a chat GPT seemed to come out of nowhere.
你知道，斯科蒂，我丈夫热爱，简直为之而活。对。我们家不能只有一个普通的电灯开关。必须是，你知道的，这个按钮控制这个，然后我可以从我的手机上操作之类的。不过现在，然后像去年11月，ChatGPT 似乎凭空出现了。
It was like, what everybody's like, what's chat GPT in like in two days? Everybody was, you can ask it this and do this. And then since then, there's been like, you know, and you hear like 50 companies coming out. So talk to me about that, where is that coming, where did it come from, why did it come out so fast,
就好像每个人都在说，ChatGPT 是什么？然后在两天之内，每个人都在说，你可以问它这个，做那个。从那以后，就像是，你知道的，你听说有50家公司冒出来。所以跟我聊聊这个，这是从哪来的，它从哪冒出来的，为什么它出来的速度这么快，
and does it scare you, or what? No, I'm not scared of AI. I'm scared of people who use AI. How's that? Like it's kind of, you know, don't be scared of the actual tech. It's like being scared of the internet, it's what people do with the internet.
这会吓到你吗，还是怎么回事？不，我没有被AI吓到。我害怕的是那些使用AI的人。这样说行吗？这就好比，你知道的，不要害怕技术本身。这就好比害怕互联网一样，可怕的是人们用互联网做了什么。
And it's not gonna suddenly become self-aware and do a terminator move. A lot of sci-fi is based on that. That these machines care about us. They don't. They don't have any opinion about us. Yeah, they're not going to lock the pod bay doors anytime. Yes, and decide, hello.
它不会突然变得有自我意识并上演终结者那一套。很多科幻小说都是基于这种设想。觉得这些机器在乎我们。它们才不在乎。它们对我们没有任何看法。对，它们才不会随时随地锁上登机舱门呢。是的，然后说：你好。
Yeah. You know, I think when the issue is a lot, this has been around for a while. And by the way, Elon think when the issue is a lot, this has been around for a while. And by the way, Elon wasn't early investor in OpenAI, which was a public, it was a nonprofit in order. Which is the company that owns Chachipati. Yes, and then it had a, it now has a capitalist arm
对。你知道，我觉得问题在于，这东西已经存在一段时间了。顺便说一句，埃隆早期曾是 OpenAI 的投资者，那是一个非营利组织。就是拥有 ChatGPT 的那家公司。是的，后来它有了资本化的分支，
and has a profit arm. But what it was was, he and others, not just him, were worried about the development of AI than that would be controlled by the Googles, the Facebooks, the apples, and the Amazon to the world. Which all have now their own AI. That's right. And so it started like that.
有了一个盈利部门。但当时的情况是，他和包括他在内的其他人，都很担心人工智能的发展会落入谷歌、Facebook、苹果和亚马逊这些大公司手中。而现在这些公司都有了自己的AI。没错。事情就是这样开始的。
And so it's being run by Sam Altman, who I have huge regard for. I really like him. He's great. Yeah, I want to be him. And no, no. He is. I don't want you to mute him. He's up again.
所以它现在由萨姆·奥尔特曼（Sam Altman）运营，我非常尊敬他。我真的很喜欢他。他太棒了。对，我想成为他。不，不。他就是。我可不想让你禁言他。他又来了。
When you're here, I don't know if you know this. They siphon through who I can see. You can't mute him. Oh, really? OK. You can see him. Also, he's a gay, by the way. He's a gay.
当你来到这里时，我不知道你知不知道。他们会过滤我能见到的人。你不能禁言他。哦，真的吗？好吧。你能看见他。顺便说一句，他也是个同性恋。他是个同性恋。
I know. I think he's a smart guy. He's a smart guy. So anyway, so what's happened is there's been a quantum leap in computing. There's been a quantum leap in the development of it. It's been going on for a long, long time, like more than a decade or longer than that machine learning and stuff like that. And so suddenly it started to take
我知道。我觉得他是个聪明人。他是个聪明人。总之，发生的情况是，计算能力实现了一次质的飞跃。它的开发实现了一次质的飞跃。这已经持续了很长时间，机器学习之类的事情已经持续了十多年甚至更久。所以突然之间，它开始取得一些飞跃，
some leaps because of computing power and scale and information. And there's these things called large language models, LLMs, that's what they call them, and it's a catchy name for them. And as we get more data, the data starts to teach itself and pattern match. That's really, I'm trying to, it's like to do an easy thing like say, you had abacuses and calculators for a while and then you got the spreadsheet. And you don't think of that. Abacai.
这是由于计算能力、规模和信息的提升。有一些东西叫做大型语言模型，也就是LLM，他们就是这么称呼它的，这是一个很抓人眼球的名字。随着我们获得更多数据，这些数据开始自我学习并进行模式匹配。真的，我正试图……这就好比打个简单的比方，你以前有算盘和计算器，然后你有了电子表格。你不会去想那个……Abacai（算盘的错误复数形式）。
Abacai, thank you. I don't know, I don't know. I have all their elements. You're so smart. Well, so it's just that the computers are becoming smarter and teaching themselves. And so artificial, it's not a really computers are becoming smart and smart and teaching themselves. And so it's not a really great word, artificial intelligence.
Abacai（算盘），谢谢。我不知道，我不知道。我有所有的元素。你真聪明。所以，这就是电脑变得越来越聪明并开始自我学习。所以，人工智能，这其实不是一个……电脑变得越来越聪明并开始自我学习。所以，这不是一个很好的词，“人工智能”。
Generative AI is the best word, is that it generates itself based on the patterns that come in the system. And GAI spells, gay. Right, gay. Gay. But Kara, it occurs to me that recently I was thinking about like, we assign the term AI,
生成式人工智能（Generative AI）才是最好的词，意思是它根据进入系统的模式自主生成内容。而 GAI 拼起来就是“同性恋”（gay）。对，gay。Gay。但是，卡拉，我突然想到，最近我在想，我们把“AI”这个词套用在所有事情上。
kind of everything. Now you go online or you're going to buy something Whatever they say and it's you know, it's AI generated or AI, you know, well, that's just more Just talking about it's just it's just technology. That's that's all it is right. No, okay, signing the okay Sorry, no, it's not it's it's different. It's it's the it's before you you know You'd search for Google and then it would come back with whatever you like, will, your name, right? You'd come back. Now it can do, it goes into the search. And so before you'd get the page related to, now you get all the information and then it gets fed back at you, which is much more interesting.
现在你上网或者买东西，不管它们说什么，都是“AI生成”或者“AI”，你知道的，好吧，那其实只是在说……这只是技术。这就是全部，对吧？不，好吧，把……对不起，不，不是的，这不一样。这是……在此之前，你知道的，你会在谷歌上搜索，然后它会返回你喜欢的东西，威尔，你的名字，对吧？它会返回结果。现在它可以做到，它深入到搜索中。所以以前你得到的是相关的网页，现在你得到了所有的信息，然后这些信息被回馈给你，这要有趣得多。
So it goes deep into the sites and then generates, you know, I'm going to France, give me a thing before you'd have to search. And now it will do things and it will be embedded in, it's now being embedded in Microsoft, in Gmail, in everything you do. And there'll be an AI for insurance, there'll be an AI for healthcare, lots of different health cares, there'll be an AI for everything, like travel.
所以它深入到网站内部然后生成，你知道的，“我要去法国，给我一个行程规划”，以前你得自己去搜。现在它会自动处理，并且会被嵌入到微软、Gmail以及你所做的每一件事中。而且会有针对保险的AI、针对医疗保健的AI（各种不同的医疗保健AI）、会有针对一切的AI，比如旅游。
And that's, it's just bringing you information faster in a way that will predict things. That's helped me understand one thing that our industry is currently battling with the strike, both in the writers and the actors. One of the issues that they're concerned about, that we are concerned about, is this, when you're talking about generative AI
这就是更快地为你提供信息，以一种能够进行预测的方式。这帮我理解了一件事，就是我们行业目前正在通过罢工与之抗争的问题，包括编剧和演员。他们关心的、我们也关心的问题之一就是这个，当你谈到生成式人工智能
and the way in which it aggregates a bunch of previously created content or performances, books, movies, all these things. So when it ingests all of these things, such that it can train itself to stick back out a result, there are people like Sarah Silverman and these novelists that are saying, well, hang on a second,
以及它聚合大量先前创作的内容或表演、书籍、电影所有这些东西的方式时。所以当它吸收了所有这些东西，以便训练自己吐出一个结果时，像萨拉·西尔弗曼（Sarah Silverman）和小说的作者们就开始说，等等一下，
you are training your model based on things that we have done and we should be like, I think, compensated or licensed, get a license for your something. How did they think, because I am assuming the horse, all of them, the millions of horses have left the barn now. No, no, no, no, because it's not protected by section 230, not of this is for, because it's not protected by Section 230.
你是在根据我们做过的事情来训练你的模型，我觉得我们应该得到补偿或授权，为你的某些东西获取授权。他们是怎么想的，因为我猜马儿，所有人，数百万匹马现在都已经跑出马厩了。不，不，不，不，因为这不受第 230 条的保护，这些都不是为了，因为它不受第 230 条的保护。
Not of this is for, it's copyright issues. And that's one of the ways they got money out of YouTube. And so what she's doing is absolutely correct. I think Barry Diller is going to do the same. A bunch of newspapers are getting together. And actually, Chad G.P.T. just licensed AP, the content for AP. So the name of the game now is to own your IP,
这些都不是为了，这是版权问题。这也是他们从 YouTube 弄到钱的方法之一。所以她做的是完全正确的。我觉得巴里·迪勒也会这么做。一群报纸正在联合起来。事实上，ChatGPT 刚刚获得了美联社的授权，即美联社内容的授权。所以现在游戏的规则是拥有你的 IP，
if you're a creator or you're an actor or whatever. And that's what you guys are arguing over. And let me just say. Let me understand that. Yeah, so let's say that somebody, so for Tracy or people like me out there that are not there. There's a lot of Jason Bateman. There's a Jason Bateman AI.
如果你是一个创作者、演员或其他什么人。这就是你们在争论的。让我直说吧。让我明白这一点。是的，所以假设有人，对于特蕾西或像我这样不在其中的人来说。有很多杰森·贝特曼。有一个杰森·贝特曼 AI。
There is. So, yeah, so I mean, I could put a prompt into an AI thing and say, give me a performance that combines Jason Bateman's role on Silver Spoons with his role on a rest of development, whatever the hell it is. And the people who own those, the people who own the show Silver Spoons and own the show rest of development, do they get compensated for that? Those performances being in the blender? Yes, but you don't, because you don't, because you signed away your content,
确实有。所以，是的，我的意思是，我可以向一个 AI 工具输入一个提示，说，给我一个表演，结合了杰森·贝特曼在《银匙》中的角色和他在《发展受阻》中的角色，不管到底是什么。那些拥有这些版权的人，拥有《银匙》和《发展受阻》这部剧版权的人，他们能因为这些表演被融合进这个搅拌机而得到补偿吗？能，但你不能，因为你不能，因为你把你的内容版权出让了，
right, so long time ago, that's why whoever owns the content, that particular content. Now, you could pot, there might be some law legal cases where you say, well, this was never imagined that it would take my face or it would take my performance.
对吧，很久以前就是这样，所以不管是谁拥有这个内容，那种特定的内容。现在，你可能，可能会有一些法律案件，你会说，好吧，从来没有人想象过它会拿走我的脸或者拿走我的表演。
But whoever owns your own ownership of IP is so important to actual property. I own all my IP right now because I want to do it. And so if Google used to just grab things and they didn't care about IP, they got in trouble for that. But they do own, they have owned a lot of your stuff, a SOTUS Facebook, they own all your stuff because you signed it when you didn't realize it. But then sorry, so I can hold onto this track.
但是无论谁拥有你自己的 IP 所有权，对实际财产来说都非常重要。我目前拥有我所有的 IP，因为我想这么做。所以如果谷歌以前只是抓取东西，他们根本不在乎 IP，他们因此遇到了麻烦。但他们确实拥有，他们拥有你们很多东西，同样还有 Facebook，他们拥有你们所有的东西，因为你在没有意识到的时候签署了它。但是等等，对不起，为了让我能跟上这个思路。
So then the people who do own Silver Spoon's Interest at the Bill and Bill, have they received a check for this use of that material in order to train these... They will. They will. They will. I think these companies are not going to, there's now a Bill and Congress that will say it's absolutely not protected. Section 230, you know what that is.
那么那些真正拥有《银匙》和《发展受阻》版权的人，他们有没有收到一张支票，因为这些材料被用来训练这些……他们会收到的。他们会的。他们会的。我觉得这些公司不会，国会现在有一项法案，上面会写着这绝对不受保护。第 230 条，你知道那是什么。
Why does that have to be retroactively challenged in the court? But well, then why didn't they receive a license even before they ingested these important resources? They didn't ingest everything. They may have made a mistake by ingesting it. They'll go have to go back and pay for any kind of copyrighted content that's under copyright. So all the things that are aggregated
为什么必须在法庭上对这个进行追溯性质疑呢？但是，既然如此，为什么他们在提取这些重要资源之前没有获得授权呢？他们并没有提取所有东西。他们可能在提取时犯了错误。他们必须回过头来，为任何属于版权保护之下的受版权保护的内容付费。所以所有聚合的东西
inside of AI that are owned by some of them are owned by them. Some of them are their own data map models. And so it'll just depend on what's in there. And so the provenance of where it came from will be your super important. But I guess what Jason saying, I think I'm chasing him to me, that their entire model is built on information that was not created by them. Right. But they might own the rights to. But they don't own the rights to all the books
在 AI 内部并由其中一部分拥有的内容归他们所有。其中一部分是他们自己的数据地图模型。所以这完全取决于里面有什么。因此，这些内容来源的出处将变得超级重要。但我想杰森的意思是，我想杰森对我说的是，他们的整个模型都建立在并非由他们创作的信息之上。没错。但他们可能拥有这些权利。但他们并不拥有所有书籍的版权
that Tom Clancy has written. If they're out of IP, they can. Right. What do you mean out of IP? What does that mean? Out of copyright. Yeah, if they're not copyrighted. Meaning it becomes public domain.
汤姆·克兰西写的书。如果它们的版权已经过期，他们就可以。对，你说的版权过期是什么意思？那是什么意思？版权过期了。是的，如果没有版权了。意思就是它成为了公共领域。
So they can take Beethoven music. They can take it. Well, the Beethoven, but that's over 100 years old. Tom's books are not 100 years old. So they're going to have to YouTube pays licensing fees. Like, there are, it does happen. And so the question is, what? They can't just grab anything, although I'll never forget.
所以他们可以使用贝多芬的音乐。他们可以使用。贝多芬的音乐当然可以，但那是100多年前的事了。汤姆的书可不到100年。所以他们将不得不——YouTube 支付许可费。你看，这是会发生的。所以问题是，什么？他们不能随心所欲地抓取任何东西，不过我永远不会忘记。
I was walking with Larry Page. You started Google at Google in the early days. And there was a room of televisions. And I said, what are you doing? They were on. Like, it was a circuit city at the time, and he said, I'm taping all of television, and I was like, what? Like, it was so crazy.
我曾和拉里·佩奇一起散步。你在早期的时候就加入了谷歌。那里有一个满是电视机的房间，我问，你们在干什么？它们开着。就像当时的电路城（Circuit City）一样，他说，我在录下所有的电视节目，我当时想，什么？天哪，太疯狂了。
The way. And he was using close captioning to search television, and I said, do you have the rights to do that? And he goes, well, it's going to be great for people to be able to search television. It's great for the company, and I said, but then you control it. Like, you can't do it without asking.
这种方式。他当时在用隐藏式字幕来搜索电视节目，我问，你们有权这样做吗？他说，这对于人们能够搜索电视节目来说太棒了。对公司也很好，我说，但那样你就掌控了它。我的意思是，你不能不经询问就这么做。
And he just was like, well, of course I can. And I was like, well, I hope they sue you. Like, because that's what's gonna happen. There's gonna be a lot of lawsuits. I think, luckily, a lot of the media companies and the publishers do understand this right now early. And they're not, they won't be able to grab a lot of copyrightwriting content very easily.
他的反应就是，嗯，我当然可以。我当时就想，好吧，我希望他们起诉你。因为接下来就会发生这种事。将会出现大量的诉讼。我想，幸运的是，很多媒体公司和出版商现在很早就明白了这一点。他们不会那么轻易地抓取到大量受版权保护的内容。
We were talking about it yesterday, the three of us were one of the things that's going on with our labor dispute that's going on in our businesses is, you know, that the companies want to be able to have this blanket usage of likeness and stuff, right? And so they're trying to do all, right? And they're claiming, you know, fuck you, we can do whatever the hell we want, and how dare you tell us what to do. Well, at the same time, we know for fact that they're involved in litigation right now
我们昨天还在谈论这件事，我们三个人讨论我们行业中正在进行的劳资纠纷时提到的一件事是，你知道的，这些公司希望能够对肖像权等内容进行全面使用，对吧？所以他们正试图做所有这些，对吧？而且他们声称，去你的，我们想干什么就干什么，你们算老几敢对我们指手画脚。好吧，与此同时，我们千真万确地知道他们目前正卷入诉讼中
to try to protect their info from being used. So they're sort of, once again, you can understand how outraged I was because, as you saw before, that I hate people who are total hypocrites. And that seems to be the name of the game. And I think, and also correct me if I'm wrong, is there is bipartisan support in Congress for solving this issue with the end. 100%. Yes, because they're going to do what they did before to publishing companies and media companies. by partisan support in Congress for solving this issue with a hundred percent.
试图保护他们自己的信息不被使用。所以他们有点，再次说明，你可以理解我当时为什么那么愤怒，因为就像你之前看到的，我讨厌那些彻头彻尾的伪君子。这似乎成了游戏规则。而且我认为，如果我没记错的话，国会有两党对解决这个问题的支持，支持率高达百分之百。百分之百。是的，因为他们要对出版公司和媒体公司做他们以前做过的事。国会有两党对解决这个问题的支持，支持率高达百分之百。
Yes, because they're going to do to what they did before to publishing companies and media companies, they're going to fuck them. And that's what they're trying to do now. They're going to have a harder time here because they're going deep into the content versus pointing to it, which gives you power. And so with you and the studios, though, I always say this to the studio heads that I talked to, and I mean, the else is,
是的，因为他们要对出版公司和媒体公司做他们以前做过的事，他们要狠狠地坑他们一把。这正是他们现在试图做的。在这里他们会遇到更大的困难，因为他们是在深入挖掘内容，而不是仅仅提供链接，而提供链接能赋予你权力。因此，关于你和那些电影公司，我总是对那些我交谈过的电影公司负责人这样说，我的意思是，其他所有人也是，
you're all on the same side against the tech companies in the end, because that's who's going to fuck you. That they have the money, they have the time, they have the means. So, you know, Netflix interests are very different than Disney's interests that are very different than Apple's interests. And so, that's your problem. And also, AI is not clear where AI is going yet, but you can anticipate that they're going to want to feed in all of Silver Spoons and make a new show that's like. But you can anticipate that they're going to want to feed in
到头来你们所有人都是站在同一战线对抗科技公司的，因为最后坑你们的就是他们。他们有钱，有时间和资源。所以，你知道的，奈飞（Netflix）的利益与迪士尼的利益大不相同，迪士尼的利益又与苹果的利益大不相同。所以，这就是你们的问题所在。而且，人工智能的走向目前还不明朗，但你可以预见，他们会想要把整部《银匙》都喂给它，然后制作一部类似的新剧。但你可以预见，他们会想要把
all of Silver Spoons and make a new show that's like that. They can do that. What happens while all this is getting sorted out and litigated, is there an injunction where AI gets frozen or does these AI companies get to continue to make profits while they figure out who's going to win or lose? And once they do lose, do they then retroactively compensate all of these.
整部《银匙》都喂进去，然后制作一部类似的新剧。他们是可以这么做的。在这一切被厘清和诉讼期间会发生什么？会有一个禁令让人工智能暂停，还是这些人工智能公司可以继续赚钱，同时去弄清楚谁会赢谁会输？一旦他们输了，他们会追溯赔偿所有人吗？
That's what happened with you two. That's what happened with you two. But that's what happens in American business. That's all they do, which is you keep going. You do whatever the fuck you want. And at a certain point, the, the, your chicken come home to roost and you've got to end up paying people back retroactively. And they're like, well, except you guys have given away a lot.
YouTube 当年就是这样的。YouTube 当年就是这样的。但这正是美国商业的运作方式。他们只会这么做，那就是你一直往前冲。你想干什么就干什么。到了某个时候，恶果自食，你的报应就要来了，你最终必须追溯赔偿人们。他们会说，好吧，不过你们这帮人已经让步太多了。
I have this argument with a guy, the rock from the sun guy. What's his name? The creator. John let's go. French Stewart. No, no, no, no, the creator of the creator. Oh, you know, Kristen Johnson. Oh, Casey Warner. Yeah, Tom Warner. No, no, no, no, no, I got.
我和一个家伙争论过，那个《歪星撞地球》（3rd Rock from the Sun）的家伙。他叫什么名字？创作者。乔恩，等一下。弗伦奇·斯图尔特（French Stewart）。不，不，不，不，《歪星撞地球》的创作者。哦，你知道的，克里斯滕·约翰逊（Kristen Johnson）。哦，凯西·华纳。对，汤姆·华纳。不，不，不，不，我知道了。
I'm going to like. I love it. No, I love him. He's great. You know, a great piece in the Washington Post. No, it's not the cast. It was the creator. I know.
我要去像。我太喜欢了。不，我太喜欢他了。他棒极了。你知道，华盛顿邮报上有一篇很棒的文章。不，不是卡斯特。是那个创作者。我知道。
I was. I'm being said. I'm sorry. His name is Terry Turner. No, Bonnie and Terry. Bon Whitteller. No, I'll find the, I'm sorry. His name is Terry Turner. No. Bonnie and Terry Turner. Bon Whitteller. No, I'll find it.
我是。我在说。对不起。他的名字是特里·特纳（Terry Turner）。不，邦妮和特里。邦·惠特勒（Bon Whitteller）。不，我会找到，对不起。他的名字是特里·特纳。不。邦妮和特里·特纳。邦·惠特勒。不，我会找到的。
I'll find it. Third rock for the son. So guy who did, or 30 rock. No, three men in the baby. Three men in the baby. No, no. A two and a half men. The two and a half men.
我会找到的。《歪星撞地球》的那个家伙，或者《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）。不，《三个奶爸一个娃》（Three Men and a Baby）。《三个奶爸一个娃》。不，不。《好汉两个半》（Two and a Half Men）。《好汉两个半》。
Chuck Laurie. Chuck Laurie. Oh my God. Be and I were sitting. Ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding sitting next to each other at a dinner on the other side was a Google executive, a very wealthy Google executive. And he Instagram just got and bought and he goes, why did that guy get so much money? Like, I think it was a billion dollars or whatever. And I said, because he owned it, Chuck, like, sorry, he owned it. And he goes, well, why should he get that? I said, because he's the owner. He owns the, he owns the company. And he has a piece of it. And I said, I said, you're a well played employee from what can tell. You sell your content to them, and then they own it.
查克·洛尔（Chuck Laurie）。查克·洛尔。天哪。我和他坐在一起。叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮，在一次晚宴上我们俩并排坐着，另一边坐着一个谷歌高管，一个非常有钱的谷歌高管。然后 Instagram 刚刚被收购，他说，为什么那家伙能拿到那么多钱？就像，我想那是十亿美元还是什么的。我说，因为那是他的，查克，抱歉，那是他拥有的。然后他说，凭什么他能得到这个？我说，因为他是所有者。他拥有公司。他拥有这家公司的一部分。我说，我听说你是个领高薪的雇员。你把你的内容卖给他们，然后他们就拥有了。
CBS. And you're the reason CBS is so valuable. And you should get a piece of that. But why don't you get a piece of that? He does. He does, but he still is not getting the piece that he created value. You know what I mean? And so, you know, he got very exercise about it.
CBS。而你就是 CBS 如此有价值的原因。你应该从中分一杯羹。但为什么你没有分到一杯羹呢？他分了。他确实分了，但他拿到的份额依然无法匹配他所创造的价值。你知道我的意思吗？所以，你知道的，他对此非常激动。
But the point is, you all have to start to rethink your entire economic system in Hollywood because either you guys are going to have to get a piece of it or have to be entrepreneurs yourselves rather than rely on studios. Well, we have to go to Wells Fargo and get the loan for production instead of the studios going to Wells Fargo to get the loan for production. You have to take the risk. But that's hard because your industry operates on fear, loathing, and insecurity, right? Yeah, right. First of all, Cara, thanks very much and have a good year. Secondly, secondly, we've got,
但关键是，你们所有人必须开始重新思考好莱坞的整个经济体系，因为要么你们得从中分一杯羹，要么你们得自己当创业者，而不是依赖电影公司。好吧，我们必须去找富国银行（Wells Fargo）贷款来制作影片，而不是让电影公司去找富国银行贷款来制作影片。你们必须承担风险。但这很难，因为你们的行业是以恐惧、厌恶和不安全感为基础运作的，对吧？是的，没错。首先，卡拉，非常感谢，祝你过个好年。其次，其次，我们，
in Hollywood, we've got our top brains on it, and we're all, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh journalism and everything since you started, why would you do it? Why do you still love it? Have you ever tried to start your own company? I have started, many companies. I have. No, I've been podcast companies, but I'm at like techie kind of stuff. Oh no, no, I'm not techie.
在好莱坞，我们有顶尖的大脑在研究这件事，我们都在，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，关于新闻业以及你刚开始时的这一切，你为什么还要这么做？你为什么依然热爱它？你有没有尝试过创办自己的公司？我创办过，很多公司。我创办过。不，我搞过播客公司，但我做的是那种偏科技的东西。哦，不，不，我不懂科技。
No, I haven't. I've been offered jobs at all the big companies. I would have been a billionaire at this point. If had I taken them, I sadly didn't. I was like, what do I need you for? I'm a journalist like a lady. I know. I had I taken them, I sadly didn't. I was like, what do I need you for? I'm a journalist. I know I had a really early Google offer. I didn't want it to Amazon. I was feeling those opportunities are not over for you.
不，我没有。所有大公司都向我提供过工作机会。如果我接受了，我当时就会成为亿万富翁了。如果我接受了的话，很遗憾我没有。我当时想，我需要你们干嘛？我是一个堂堂正正的记者。我懂的。如果我接受了的话，很遗憾我当时没有。我当时想，我需要你们干嘛？我是一个记者。我知道我曾经很早就拿到过谷歌的工作邀请。我不想要，还有亚马逊的。我觉得那些机会对你来说并没有结束。
I doubt, but definitely. You put your hand up. You get gobbled. I decided to innovate with journalism. And so I broke away from the Wall Street Journal, created my own company. Now everybody's doing it like sub-stack and stuff like that. Created a conference company, it's highly lucrative. So the reason I was attracted is because I was at the Washington Post, and I was headed for the big time, which would have been covering the Clinton administration, and I just couldn't do it. I was like, this is not what I want to do, cover politics and be part of it thing,
我怀疑，但绝对是的。你举起手来。你就会被吞并。我决定用新闻业进行创新。所以我离开了《华尔街日报》，创立了自己的公司。现在每个人都在这么做，比如 Substack 之类的。我还创办了一家会议公司，非常赚钱。我之所以被吸引，是因为我当时在《华尔街日报》，正朝着大好前程迈进，那将是报道克林顿政府，但我实在做不到。我当时想，这不是我想做的事，去报道政治并成为其中的一部分，
and I just kept seeing, I went to this fellowship at Duke and started using early internet tools. And I downloaded a book onto my computer. And I messed up the whole network at Duke at the time. And the guy was mad at me, this nerdy guy was like, what did you do? I said, I downloaded a book. He said, yeah, I clogged the pipe. And he goes, he goes, you made a mess. And I said, I downloaded a book, you asshole. And he goes, you clogged up the pipe. I said, but I downloaded a book. And I said, then everything could be downloaded.
我只是不断看到，我去了杜克大学参加那个学术研究项目，并开始使用早期的互联网工具。我在电脑上下载了一本书。当时我把杜克大学的整个网络都弄瘫痪了。那家伙对我很生气，那个书呆子气十足的家伙问，你干了什么？我说，我下载了一本书。他说，对，你把管道堵塞了。然后他说，他说，你搞砸了。我说，我下载了一本书，你个混蛋。他说，你把管道堵塞了。我说，但我下载了一本书。然后我说，那么所有东西都可以被下载了。
And so it occurred to me at that moment. And this was back in the 90s that everything that can be digitized would be digitized. And that was, that's, I was like, oh, well, that's, that's like the Gutenberg Bible. That's like radio, television, except bigger. And it's a worldwide network of information. So the minute it happened, I was like, oh, I see.
所以我在那个瞬间突然意识到。那是 90 年代，所有可以数字化的一切都将被数字化。那就是，我当时想，哦，好吧，这就像古腾堡圣经。这就像广播、电视，只不过规模更大。这是一个全球性的信息网络。所以事情发生的瞬间，我心想，哦，我明白了。
This is a big fucking deal. This is so, that's all. Wow. And now, a word from our sponsor. Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. If you're anything like me, you stay up at night with your mind racing, racing, racing, right?
这可真是个了不得的大事。就是这样，好了。现在，听听我们赞助商的话。Smartless 由 BetterHelp 赞助。如果你和我有点像，你会在夜里辗转反侧，脑子里思绪万千，转个不停，对吧？
I get up, like, if I get up to pee, I will then stay up because I'm up and my mind will race trying to get things done. I'll even send emails and texts and everything just to get work done while I'm up at 2, 3, 4, 5 in the morning, whatever it is. And I can't stop the racing thoughts, right? They just continue and continue and continue. It's probably a form of anxiety or something. I don't know.
我起来，比如，如果我起来上厕所，我就会一直醒着，因为我醒了，我的脑子就会飞速运转，想着把事情做完。我甚至会发电子邮件、发短信等等，只是为了在凌晨 2 点、3 点、4 点、5 点不管什么时候醒着的时候把工作干完。而且我停不下这些狂飙的思绪，对吧？它们就是不断地、不断地、不断地继续。这可能是一种焦虑症什么的。我不知道。
But do you ever find that just as you're trying to fall asleep, your brain suddenly won't stop talking? Do your thoughts start racing right before bed or at other in-opportune moments like me? It turns out one great way to make those racing thoughts go away is to talk them through. Therapy gives you a place to do that, so you can get out of your negative thought cycles
但是你有没有发现，就在你试图入睡时，你的大脑突然开始说个不停？就在你睡觉前或者其他不合时宜的时刻，比如我，你的思绪是不是开始狂飙？事实证明，让这些狂飙的思绪平息下来的一个好方法就是把它们说出来。心理治疗为你提供了一个这样做的地方，这样你就能摆脱消极的思维循环，
and find some mental and emotional piece. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help, a try. So you can get out of your negative thought cycles and find some mental and emotional piece. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help, a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists
并找到一些精神和情感上的平静。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试 BetterHelp。这样你就能摆脱消极的思维循环，并找到一些精神和情感上的平静。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在线上，旨在提供便利、灵活的服务，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与获得执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时更换治疗师，
any time for no additional charge. I've said this before many, many times on our little podcast that therapy has really been beneficial to me. It really, really does help to talk out your issues and even racing thoughts, which is a big one for me. So, guys, I really encourage you to give it a try. Get a break from your thoughts with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com-smartless today to get 10% off your first month.
无需支付额外费用。我以前在这个小播客上说过很多很多次，心理治疗对我真的很有益。把你的问题甚至狂飙的思绪说出来，真的、真的很有帮助，这对我来说是个大问题。所以，伙计们，我真的鼓励你们去试试。通过 BetterHelp 从你的思绪中获得片刻喘息。今天就访问 betterhelp.com-smartless，在第一个月享受 9 折优惠。
That's BetterHelp-HELP.com-smartless. It's better help help.com slash smartless. This episode is brought to you in part by 8 sleep. Did you know that temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality? When you wake up at the middle of the night or feel extra groggy in the morning, temperature is usually the one to blame. Well, the pod cover by eight sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet and will improve your sleep by
网址是 BetterHelp-HELP.com-smartless。也就是 better help help.com 斜杠 smartless。本集部分内容由 Eight Sleep 赞助。你知道温度是改善睡眠质量最重要的因素之一吗？当你半夜醒来或者早晨感觉格外疲惫时，通常都怪温度。嗯，Eight Sleep 的 Pod 智能床罩可以像床单一样套在任何床垫上，并通过
automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed based on you and your partner's individual needs. So it turns out I'm talking to Rob, old Rob, I'm Yerf over here on the on the pod, and he suffers from the same thing. So we all get eight sleeps. Rob and Bennett both put them on first, like first week and I was out of town so I haven't had a chance to put it on my bed yet. And they start swearing by it. Rob claims, and by the way, unprompted, he claims that this thing has eliminated his normal 3 a.m. wake up, that he sleeps with the night. And it tracks your sleep and you and your partner so as Rob
根据你和伴侣的个人需求自动调节床铺两侧的温度来改善你的睡眠。事实证明，我和罗布在聊，老罗布，我在播客里管他叫耶夫，他也饱受同样的困扰。所以我们都买了 Eight Sleep。罗布和本特最先把它们装上，比如第一周就装了，而我当时不在城里，所以我还没机会把它装在我的床上。他们开始对它赞不绝口。罗布声称，顺便说一句，这是未经提醒的，他声称这东西彻底消除了他通常在凌晨 3 点醒来的习惯，他能一觉睡到天亮。它会追踪你的睡眠，你和你的伴侣都可以像罗布
and his wife can look at their sort of sleep performance from the night before and I hate to say they're really competitive about it. And so while it's fixed their sleep, it's really damaged their marriage. I'm joking, of course. So for me, that is the thing that is the most annoying is waking up in the middle of the night for no reason and it turns out this whole time it's been about temperature. So thanks to the pod's sleep and health tracking. Like I said, you can wake up to a personalized sleep report for you each morning that offers insights into, you know, how certain behaviors like late night exercise or caffeine or whatever impact your sleep and overall health.
和他的妻子一样，可以查看他们前一晚的睡眠表现，我讨厌这么说，他们对此真的竞争意识极强。所以虽然它修复了他们的睡眠，但真的损害了他们的婚姻。我当然是在开玩笑。所以对我来说，最烦人的事情就是毫无理由地半夜醒来，结果发现这么长时间以来问题都出在温度上。多亏了 Pod 的睡眠和健康追踪功能。就像我说的，你每天早晨都可以醒来看到一份为你量身定制的睡眠报告，其中提供了各种洞察，比如，你知道的，诸如深夜锻炼、咖啡因等特定行为是如何影响你的睡眠和整体健康的。
Invest in the rest you deserve with the 8-Sleep Pod. Go to 8sleep.com slash smartless and save $150 on the pod cover by 8-Sleep. That's the best offer you'll find. But you must visit 8sleep.com slash smartless for $150 off. 8-Sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK, select countries in the EU and Australia, good night mate. Thanks to one of our new sponsors Mudwater for the sport. We've been drinking Mudwater. It's a coffee alternative with four functional mushrooms and with only a fraction of caffeine as a cup of coffee.
投资于你应得的休息，选择 Eight Sleep Pod。访问 8sleep.com/smartless，购买 Eight Sleep Pod 床罩即可省下 150 美元。这是你能找到的优惠。但你必须访问 8sleep.com/smartless 才能享受 150 美元的优惠。Eight Sleep 目前在美国、加拿大、英国、欧盟部分国家和澳大利亚发货，晚安，伙计。感谢我们的新赞助商 Mudwater 对节目的支持。我们一直在喝 Mudwater。这是一种咖啡替代品，含有四种功能性蘑菇，咖啡因含量仅为一杯咖啡的一小部分。
You get energy without the jitters or crash of coffee. For me, like a lot of people, I like my morning routine. I like waking up and having my first hot beverage and sort of sorting through my stuff and sometimes it's playing nerdle and sometimes it's, but just having that thing that I do in putting mud water now, front and center in the middle of my routine has just made my mornings that much better.
你能获得能量，而没有喝咖啡带来的心神不宁或精力崩溃。对我来说，和很多人一样，我喜欢我的早晨例行公事。我喜欢醒来喝我的第一杯热饮，然后整理一下我的东西，有时候是玩文字游戏（nerdle），有时候是别的，但只要有那件我必做的事，现在把 mud water 放在我早晨日常的中心位置，就让我的早晨变得好得多了。
You can drink it with all the stuff that you normally drink coffee with, you know, honey or oat milk or whatever it is that you want, but you get all these great benefits, and you don't get that sort of jittery after effect that you feel after a couple cups of coffee, which is the thing that always bums me out about drinking too much coffee.
你可以用你平时喝咖啡时加的所有东西来冲泡它，你知道的，比如蜂蜜、燕麦奶或者任何你想要的，但你能获得所有这些极好的益处，而且不会感受到喝了满满几杯咖啡之后感到的那种心神不宁的后劲，这也是喝太多咖啡总是让我感到沮丧的地方。
I don't like that feeling. I get sort of sweaty and I get kind of, I feel crappy, my stomach kind of hurts, and all that kind of stuff. The thing with mud water is that each ingredient was added for a purpose. Coco and Chai for a hint of caffeine and hot chocolate-like flavor,
我不喜欢那种感觉。我会开始出汗，感觉怪怪的，觉得很不舒服，我的胃也会有点痛，诸如此类的事。Mudwater 的妙处在于，它的每一种成分都是为了一个目的而添加的。可可和印度奶茶带来一丝咖啡因和类似热巧克的风味，
lines main to support focus, courticeps to help support physical performance and both Chaga and Rishi to support your immune system. Mud is whole 30 approved, 100% organic, non-GMO gluten-free vegan and kosher certified. Mudwater donates monthly to psychedelic research and treatments as they believe the country is in a mental health epidemic
狮鬃菇（lion's mane）用于支持专注力，冬虫夏草（cordyceps）用于支持体能表现，而白桦茸（Chaga）和灵芝（Reishi）则用于支持你的免疫系统。Mud 获得过 Whole30 认证，100% 有机、非转基因、无麸质、纯素且符合犹太洁食认证。Mudwater 每月向迷幻药研究和治疗捐款，因为他们相信美国正处于心理健康危机中，
and sees psychedelics as useful tools for individuals with depression, PTSD, anxiety, and other mental health experiences. So get 15% off and a free froth or at mudwater.com slash martinus code smartless for 15% off. M-U-D-W-T-R dot com slash smartless code smartless. and use code SmartLess for 15% off. MUDWTR.com slash SmartLess. Code SmartLess.
并将迷幻药视为患有抑郁症、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、焦虑症和其他心理健康困扰的个人的有用工具。访问 mudwater.com/smartless 使用优惠码 smartless 即可享受 8.5 折优惠并获赠一个免费奶泡器。网址是 MUDWTR.com/smartless，优惠码为 smartless。使用优惠码 SmartLess 可享 8.5 折优惠。MUDWTR.com/smartless，优惠码 SmartLess。
And now back to the show. It seems like every industry would benefit from an equally devised council. In other words, thoughts and interests equally represented from both sides, whatever those are, in every industry to figure out and to be creative and curious about what the potential problems and pluses are from this specific thing, this AI thing. Because, like we're dealing with these strikes right now, I think everybody kind of agrees, we don't have brains big enough to figure out how to language everything specifically
现在回到节目中。看起来每个行业都会受益于一个同样构思出来的委员会。换句话说，在每个行业中，来自双方的思想和利益都得到平等的代表，无论这些双方是什么，来弄清楚并对这个特定事物（这个人工智能事物）的潜在问题和积极方面保持创造力和好奇心。因为，就像我们现在正在应对这些罢工一样，我想大家基本上都同意，我们的脑容量还不够大，无法弄清楚如何将所有东西具体地用语言表述
into this term of contract. We're going to need these next three years to really figure out the micro, but what is the language for the macro foundational stuff, such that as we start to learn the specifics of how this stuff benefits us or hurts us, the language is already established that we can make it all fair as we go forward. Where are the brains that can fill these rooms? Hey, Jay, I've noticed something and this is sort of related. I think that Jason, you would have been, you would have, you'd make a really good Canadian
到这个合同条款中。我们需要接下来的三年时间来真正弄清楚微观层面，但宏观基础事物的语言应该是什么样的，这样当我们开始了解这东西如何使我们受益或伤害我们的具体细节时，语言就已经建立好了，随着我们前进，我们可以让这一切都变得公平。能填满这些房间的大脑在哪里？嘿，杰伊，我注意到了一件事，这有点相关。我觉得杰森，你本来会，你本来会，你会成为一个非常优秀的加拿大人，
because this is not the first time you've talked about the idea of like, we should, there should be a broadcaster, there should be a consensus given by a government agency that we can all turn to. I mean, you're really, you would make a, you would fit right in Canada. Yeah, yeah. And I mean, that is a compliment. I really, I truly do. Listen, I love it up there. I definitely really do. But you know, you guys are creative. Look at Sean just did with his show. I really, I truly do. Listen, I love it up there. I really do. But you know, you guys are creative. Look at Sean just did with his show. You know, creativity is not going to be digitized easily at all by, in any way, creativity
因为这已经不是你第一次谈论这种想法了，比如，我们应该，应该有一个广播公司，应该有一个由政府机构给出的共识，我们可以向其求助。我的意思是，你真的很，你会成为一个，你会非常适合加拿大。对，对。我的意思是，这是一个赞美。我真的，我确实这么觉得。听着，我喜欢那里。我绝对真的很喜欢。但你知道，你们很有创造力。看看肖恩刚刚用他的节目做了什么。我真的，我确实这么觉得。听着，我喜欢那里。我真的喜欢。但你知道，你们很有创造力。看看肖恩刚刚用他的节目做了什么。你知道，创造力根本不会轻易被数字化，以任何方式，创造力和
and entrepreneurship. They can't copy Quirk. They can't. And that's powerful. That's powerful. But Elon Musk can try. But I got rapid fire like last three questions because I got to let you go. They're not going to let you go.
企业家精神。他们无法复制 Quirk。他们做不到。这就是力量。这就是力量。但埃隆·马斯克可以尝试。但我得快点问最后三个问题，因为我得放你走了。他们可不会轻易放你走。
We have you like 10 questions for Chris. Okay, sure. Well, I want to talk about military intelligence because you're like. You'll love the Apple Vision Pro, Will. Really? I'm going to get a demo of it next week. Good. I was supposed to go and I'm Jason's there and I'm not.
我们有像 10 个问题要问克里斯。好吧，当然。我想谈谈军事情报，因为你像。你会喜欢 Apple Vision Pro 的，威尔。真的吗？我下周要去看个演示。太好了。我本该去的，结果杰森去了，而我没去。
You know what? It's not quite there yet, but you'll, if you get it, you'll get it. Caratel, my sister Tracy, what that is. Apple Vision Pro is a headset. It's like the Oculus, but it's very different. It's going to get it, you'll get it. Caratel, my sister Tracy, what that is. Apple Vision Pro is a headset. It's like the Oculus, but it's very different. It's gonna, it's gonna change work. It's like ski goggles, but you can see stuff inside it. Yeah, you can see through them, actually.
你知道吗？它现在还没完全做好，但是你会，如果你拿到了，你就会懂的。卡拉特，我妹妹特蕾西，那是什么东西。Apple Vision Pro 是一款头显。它有点像 Oculus，但非常不同。如果你拿到了，你就会懂的。卡拉特，我妹妹特蕾西，那是什么东西。Apple Vision Pro 是一款头显。它有点像 Oculus，但非常不同。它将，它将改变工作方式。它就像滑雪镜，但你能在里面看到东西。对，其实你能透过它们看到外面。
How's it gonna change work, Carat, just quickly? Because you're not gonna need a screen. You know, everyone's like, it costs $3,000. They said a really nice screen costs $3,000. I think you're gonna have the screens in front of you. And when it gets lighter and better, to have the screens in front of you. And when it gets lighter and better, you'll be working in front of you. Head's up display is the way it's going to go.
卡拉，它将如何改变工作方式，简单说一下？因为你不需要屏幕了。你知道，每个人都说，它要 3000 美元。他们说一个非常好的屏幕就要 3000 美元。我觉得你会在面前拥有这些屏幕。当它变得更轻、更好时，把屏幕放在你面前。当它变得更轻、更好时，你将在它面前工作。平视显示器（Head's up display）将是未来的发展方向。
100%. And this is the first step there. You'll really enjoy it. And touch the dinosaur, Jason. Touch the dinosaur. Touch the dinosaur. You'll know what I mean. That's not a euphemism, right?
百分之百。这是迈出的第一步。你会非常喜欢它的。去摸摸恐龙，杰森。去摸摸恐龙。去摸摸恐龙。你就明白我的意思了。那不是什么委婉说法吧？
I mean, it's just, OK. porn will be really good with this. Porn will be amazing. Trampstamp, it says touch the dinosaur. But Carol, remember the Google glasses? Like, why not that? Yeah, that's, I have a pair. I just found my pair the other day
我的意思是，好吧。用这个看色情片一定很棒。看色情片会爽到爆。后腰纹身（Trampstamp），上面写着去摸摸恐龙。但是卡拉，还记得谷歌眼镜（Google glasses）吗？为什么不是那个？对，那个，我有一副。我前几天刚找到我那一副，
because it wasn't right, because it was too, but then nobody's gonna walk around with the whole thing over here. It's not gonna look like that. Nobody's gonna come down. Calm down. Look at the early internet. The internet looks like shit.
因为它不对劲，因为它太，但接下来没有人会把整个这玩意儿戴在头上到处晃悠。它看起来才不那样呢。没有人会走下来。冷静点。看看早期的互联网。互联网看起来像狗屎一样。
Everything looks like shit at the beginning. Remember the headphones, airpods? Sean, nobody's walking around to go anywhere. Sean, look at your baby pictures. Everybody's going to go into the glasses. It'll look like your glasses. I told you, it's like the automated car. We're all going to be getting an automated car.
一开始所有东西看起来都像狗屎。还记得那些耳机，AirPods 吗？肖恩，没有人会戴着这东西到处走。肖恩，看看你小时候的照片。每个人都会戴上这种眼镜。它看起来就会像你的眼镜。我跟你说过，就像自动驾驶汽车一样。我们以后都会坐上自动驾驶汽车。
As people are going to be showing up at redress. I just did it yesterday with my son. Yeah, you're going to order one. The user report is going to be dead in it. No, no. Show up and then the fucking these things are gonna be great coffins good. No, no I just rode the Waymo yesterday around You didn't go with my son my son the waymo. What is it? Waymo is owned by Google and then there's crews by GM And then there's a list by Amazon driver list Uber no people in the cars. Why would you ever get into that?
当人们开始出现在雷德雷斯（redress）时。我昨天刚和我儿子一起试过。对，你会订一辆的。用户报告里肯定没戏了。不，不。一出现，然后这该死的东西就会变成绝佳的棺材，好吧。不，不，我昨天刚在周围坐了 Waymo。你没跟我儿子一起，我儿子坐了 Waymo。那是什么？Waymo 是谷歌旗下的，然后还有通用汽车旗下的 Cruise，还有亚马逊旗下的，驾驶列表——优步（Uber）里没有司机。你怎么会想坐那玩意儿？
It's so cool I'll send you the video is it like a noober? Can you ever get into that? It's so cool. I'll send you the video. Is it like an Uber? Can you text me that video? It's like a neuter. Yes, I just put them up on the rest. It's a rideshare thing. Like a rideshare thing and you call it.
太酷了，我把视频发给你。它就像一辆优步（noober）吗？你敢坐那种车吗？太酷了。我把视频发给你。它就像一辆优步吗？你能把那个视频发短信给我吗？它就像个无人的优步。是的，我刚把它发到网上。它是个拼车服务。就像拼车服务一样，你叫一辆。
They have them in LA. I've seen it in LA. They're just starting in LA. They're just, they're, they're, they're in testing right now. But they're in Phoenix going to the airport now and in Houston. They have long haul trucks in Texas doing a driver's house. They should offer helmets to the riders just for the first year. You don't need it.
他们在洛杉矶有这玩意儿。我在洛杉矶见过。他们刚开始在洛杉矶推出。他们只是，他们，他们，他们目前处于测试阶段。但他们在菲尼克斯（Phoenix）已经可以去机场了，在休斯敦也有。他们在得克萨斯州有长途卡车，实现无人驾驶。他们应该给乘客提供头盔，就当是第一年。你不需要那玩意儿。
You get in a car with an Uber driver who's like 16 and you're good with that. I'm sorry. I can't wait to do it again in one of those and get it and join the foot and a half club. I have ridden these things. Ha ha. Yeah, with your girl.
你坐上一个 16 岁优步司机的车，你也挺放心的。抱歉。我迫不及待地想再次坐那玩艺儿，加入一脚半俱乐部。我坐过这东西。哈哈。对，和你的女朋友。
Really nice. You would do that anyway with someone in the front seat as my ass. I would. You're a good one. I want nice. You would do that anyway with someone in the front seat as my ass, but I want to know about okay, so just okay. Well, I wanted to get into military intelligence because I know you are into that. I just like I don't want to. Millage, okay. Tell me about that. Like because you grew up like learning about it and then you and then you pivoted right or something or your dad was. I couldn't go in military because I was gay Sean that was why it was don't ask don't tell and I'd like to tell yeah remember that remember you made them ask I made them I couldn't be a military because I was gay my fan
真不错。反正如果前排坐着人，你也会这么干的，就像我的屁股一样。我会的。你真行。我想要美好的。反正如果前排坐着人，你也会这么干的，就像我的屁股一样，但我想了解——好吧，那就——好吧。我想谈谈军事情报，我知道你对那很感兴趣。我只是——我不想。军事，好吧。跟我讲讲那个。因为你从小就了解它，然后你，然后你转型了还是怎么的，或者你爸爸是。我不能参军，因为我是同性恋，肖恩，原因就是“不问不说”（don't ask, don't tell），而我想说。是的，记得那个吗？记得你逼他们问吗？我逼他们——我不能参军，因为我是同性恋，我的粉丝——
my dad's me fucking ask me fucking I'll tell you I'll kiss her kiss her and then you're gonna ask me and then you're gonna ask me and I'm gonna tell thank you Bill Clinton for that by the way well that's too big of a question. We'll get into that next time. But what is the, what is the, what's your favorite new techie gadget of the year of the last 10 years? Is it this dumb ride that I'm never going to get into? Is it the Google thing with the VR? I love, no, it's Apple. It's Apple. Apple, sorry. I really am really heartened by these autonomous cars. I have ridden them for 20 years and they are really getting good. They're getting good.
我爸爸——逼我问——逼我问——我要告诉你——亲她，亲她，然后你就要问我，然后你就要问我，然后我要告诉你，谢谢你，比尔·克林顿，因为这个。好吧，这个问题太大了。我们下次再聊。但是，那个是什么，那个，你过去十年里最喜欢的科技新玩意儿是什么？是这个我永远不会去坐的傻逼车吗？是谷歌的那个 VR 设备吗？我喜欢，不，是苹果。是苹果。苹果，抱歉。我真的对这些自动驾驶汽车感到非常鼓舞。我已经坐了 20 年了，它们真的越来越好了。它们越来越好了。
They're getting real good. And so I... The truck thing is an issue though, right? No. Because that's a lot of drivers that are going to go out of work. You know, who gets an accident? No, it's not. There's not enough drivers in this country.
它们真的变得越来越好了。所以我……卡车那事儿是个问题吧，对吧？不。因为那会使很多司机失业。你知道谁会出车祸吗？不，不是这样的。这个国家的司机根本不够。
There's a hundred, we're down a hundred thousand drivers. Oh, really? Instead, you have the long haul. Long haul shouldn't be done by people FYI. It's very dangerous and it's not good work. And so what you do is you have the autonomous trucks do the long haul and then in short terms into the cities, you have people do them. So there's all kinds of, and then there's job opportunities to run them and there's, it's
我们有十万，我们缺口十万名司机。哦，真的吗？相反，你有长途运输。长途运输本不应该由人来做，供你参考。这非常危险，而且不是什么好工作。所以你所做的是，让自动驾驶卡车来跑长途，然后在短途进入城市时，由人来驾驶。所以有各种各样的，而且还有运营它们的就业机会，这是
a false argument to say we have enough for this. You know, and a lot of these automated robots are becoming drunks. And so they're forming. Yeah. Tell me what alcoholics autonomous. It's so. So you're funnier than Elon Musk. I'm not.
一个虚假的论点，说什么我们的司机足够多了。你知道，而且很多这种自动化机器人正在变成酒鬼。所以它们正在形成。是的。告诉我什么是匿名酒鬼（alcoholics autonomous）。太好笑了。所以你比埃隆·马斯克更有趣。我没有。
I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. That was an Elon Musk joke. Just FYI. That was something. I'm.
我没有。我没有。我没有。那是一个埃隆·马斯克式的笑话。仅供参考。那是某个。我。
What's the opposite of artificial intelligence? What? Here it comes. Natural stupidity. Hey guys. So, Karen, tell me about the greatest military invention of the last few years. I think the Starlink, the Starlink what it's doing in Ukraine is really important. It is. It is.
人工智能的反义词是什么？什么？来了。天然愚蠢。嘿，伙计们。所以，卡拉，跟我讲讲过去几年最伟大的军事发明。我认为星链（Starlink），星链在乌克兰发挥的作用真的很重要。确实如此。确实如此。
It's. Now, when you were a kid, these are, and then we're going to let you go. Because now, these are the things I worked on that I want to know. I can't imagine, like, I would have killed to know you as a kid. Like, we would have been best friends. Best friends. But what do you, Princeton New Jersey? I can't imagine working at KFC or something.
它。现在，当你还是个孩子的时候，这些是，然后我们就要放你走了。因为现在，这些是我研究过的事情，我想知道。我无法想象，比如，我会为了认识小时候的你而付出一切。比如，我们本来会是最好的朋友。最好的朋友。但你，新泽西州普林斯顿？我无法想象在肯德基或其他什么地方工作。
Like, what is like the first, did you ever work? What was your first job? I was an entrepreneur. I took pictures of people for their senior pictures. So you were a little photographer, like a little photographer. Yeah, really? At a dark room. Creepy.
比如，第一份工作是什么，你工作过吗？你的第一份工作是什么？我是一个创业者。我给人们拍毕业照。所以你是个小摄影师，就像一个小摄影师。对，真的吗？在一个暗室里。毛骨悚然。
Did you hold on to all the photos and then load them online and digitize them then only IP? Fuck you, Cara. Do you ever come down to Los Angeles so we can see face to face and share a meal? Yes, I come in, yes, 100%. Will you come and have dinner with us?
你把所有照片都留着，然后传到网上数字化，然后就只在IP上？去你的，卡拉。你有没有来过洛杉矶，这样我们就能面对面一起吃顿饭了？对，我会去，对，百分之百会。你会来和我们一起吃晚饭吗？
Yes, I probably, if you mean it, unless it's just fake and that's what I'm talking about. No, it's not Hollywood fake. I'll speak for me, I wanna be your friend. I need more smart people in my life. Yes, I'd be happy too. I love Los Angeles, one of my favorite places. Last question I have, do you ever take a break from tech?
会的，我可能会的，如果你是认真的，除非这只是假客套，而这就是我所说的。不，这不是好莱坞式的虚伪。我只代表我自己，我想成为你的朋友。我的生活中需要更多聪明的人。对，我也很乐意。我喜欢洛杉矶，我最喜欢的地方之一。我的最后一个问题，你平时会远离科技产品吗？
You have me phone, from your phone, from your theater. Yes, I have four children, I mean, I have Sean, excuse me, I'm calling you Scott, I just did Tivot. I have four children, yes. No, but I mean, do you Sean, excuse me, I'm calling you Scott, I just did Tivot. I have four children, yes, I do. No, but I mean, like, do you ever do like a schedule two weeks or not going to do, you know, one of those things? No, no, I'm working all the time. What do you do to dumb down?
你手里有我，从你的手机、你的剧院。对，我有四个孩子，我是说，我有肖恩，对不起，我刚才叫你斯科特，我刚才在弄Tivo。我有四个孩子，是的。不，我是说，肖恩，对不起，我刚才叫你斯科特，我刚才在弄Tivo。我有四个孩子，是的，我有。不，我的意思是，比如说，你有没有过两周左右的计划，或者不去做，你知道，那种事情？不，不，我一直在工作。你通过什么来放松大脑？
What's the dumbest thing you do? I went to see Barbie twice. No, I love Barbie, I think it's brilliant actually. You know, I do things like the succession podcast, which is I'm a big fan, I had enjoyed that. For example, dumb down, TV. I watch TV mindlessly. Rewatching some bad TV. No, I think it's good. Whatever. I like, you know who I like, the guy who's in play, Jared Butler. I love Jared Butler. Jared Butler. I love him. I don't know
你做过最蠢的事是什么？我去看过两次《芭比》。不，我很喜欢《芭比》，我觉得它其实很精彩。你知道的，我会做一些像听《继承之战》播客之类的事，我是个超级粉丝，我很喜欢那个。比如说，放松大脑，看电视。我毫无目的地看电视。重看一些烂电视。不，我觉得挺好的。随便吧。我喜欢，你知道我喜欢谁吗，那个演电影的家伙，杰瑞德·巴特勒。我太喜欢杰瑞德·巴特勒了。杰瑞德·巴特勒。我太喜欢他了。我不知道
why. I don't even know his name. I, you know, and know, and I, and I, Liam Neeson has a new movie that he beats people. I like that. Listen, Karen. Do you ever? I don't care. Karen, just kill someone for me. It's a hug that's missing something and needs to find it. You're in.
为什么。我甚至都不知道他的名字。我，你知道，还有，我，连姆·尼森有一部新电影，里面他在揍人。我喜欢那个。听着，凯伦。你有没有？我不在乎。凯伦，随便帮我杀个人吧。这是一个缺少了某样东西并需要找到它的拥抱。你赢了。
Let me ask you something. I'm going to prescribe something to you. I'm going to write this down. I'm going to write it in my perspective. I'm going to pet it. I want you to do it right now. Okay. I want you to go.
我问你个事。我要给你开个处方。我要把它写下来。我要从我的角度来写。我要抚摸它。我希望你现在就照做。好吧。我希望你去。
Yeah. Uncelested advice from a white guy. Great. I want to take it and take your shoes off and I want to put your, I want you to put your bare feet on the grass. Oh, don't do that. I have to listen to kind of people on this bowl. Is this the long island girl girl? Go ahead. Put your bare feet on the grass in the sand. You know what?
太棒了，来自白男的未经请求的建议。好。我想让你把鞋脱掉，然后把你的，我想让你把赤脚放在草地上。哦，别那样。我得听这种人在这个节目里废话。这是那个长岛女孩吗？去吧。把你的赤脚踩在草地和沙滩上。你知道吗？
I have one of those black cats. This connect from, this connect from your tag, from your tag. No, no, no. I love my tag. I'm going to, when I was having a baby, this is my last break. I was having my son. I was holding a blackberry in texting me. Yeah.
我有一个那样的黑莓。这个断开，从你的标签，从你的标签。不，不，不。我爱我的标签。我要，自我生孩子时起，这是我最后一个假期。我当时正生着我儿子。我手里拿着一部黑莓在发短信。对。
Were you really that? I love it. Well, I got an emergency seat section and I was texting Walt Mossberg, who was a great technology journalist, and he was my partner at all the things I did. I was texting him saying eight centimeters, seven, so whatever the centimeters was. And I had an emergency C-section, they rushed me into the room and it was in my hand, it was a square little thing.
你真的是那样吗？我太喜欢了。好吧，我做了紧急剖腹产，当时我正在给沃尔特·莫斯伯格发短信，他是一位伟大的科技记者，他是我所做一切事情的合作伙伴。我发短信告诉他宫口开到八厘米了、七厘米，不管当时是多少厘米。然后我做了紧急剖腹产，他们把我推进产房，它还抓在我手里，那是一个方方正正的小东西。
And my brother was a doctor at this hospital and the doctor looked at me and they said, your brother said you'd be a problem around the tech. And so they covered my, they covered the blackberry in a plastic bag and then they taped it because you know, like germs. And so it sat there buzzing the entire C-section. It's a great moment in my life. That's just there. Do you, where you were one of those parents,
我哥哥是这家医院的医生，医生看着我，他们说，你哥说你带着科技产品会是个麻烦。于是他们用一个塑料袋把黑莓包起来，然后用胶带封好，因为你知道的，就像防细菌一样。于是它就在那里嗡嗡作响地度过了整个剖腹产手术。这是我生命中的一个伟大时刻。它就在那儿。你，你是不是那种父母，
we were like, because I know you're a great mom. Yeah. Did you tell them, like, put the tablet down, put your phone down, or you're like, yeah, do whatever you want. No, because my ex-wife, and I, I married twice, my ex-wife used to be the chief technology officer of the United States and was a Google executive, so they couldn't put anything over on either of us.
我们当时，因为我知道你是个好妈妈。对。你会不会对他们说，比如，把平板放下，把手机放下，还是说，随便你们想干嘛都行？不，因为我的前妻，我结过两次婚，我的前妻曾任美国首席技术官，也是谷歌的高管，所以他们谁也别想在我们俩眼皮底下搞鬼。
So we had full control of the situation. And I also could call people one time when my sons were doing too much Snapchat. I was somewhere and I brought them in a room. And I said, here is Evan Spiegel, the creator, and we're going to off your snapchat. And they were like, if you don't stop using it, he goes, yes, I'm going to.
所以我们对整个局面有完全的控制权。而且我还给别人打过电话，有一次我儿子们玩Snapchat太厉害了。我当时在某个地方，把他们叫到一个房间里。我说，这位是埃文·斯皮格尔，创始人，我们要把你们的snapchat账号给封了。然后他们就，如果你再不停下来用它，他就说，是的，我要封了。
It was perfect. I love that. I love that. Steve Jobs, we did a few jobs. Karen, Swisher, I love you. And I love that you're such a great mom. Thank you. Well, that was five minutes long.
太完美了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。史蒂夫·乔布斯，我们做了几个工作。凯伦·斯维什，我爱你。我喜欢你是个这么棒的妈妈。谢谢。好吧，那段有五分钟长。
That was five minutes long. My God, he's come back. Yeah, we need to do a part to it. I feel like we're just too barely scratched the surface. You would have been so much better. We were so happy. We were supposed to have you. We were supposed to have you on the trip. What happened? What happened? You remember what happened? What happened with that shot? Famous people. No, you put so many fame. What a dick. I don't care. No, no. I know. I do. You know, be more famous than all of you. I know. That's true. We are you doing? No. know, that's cool. Weater, you doing? No.
那段有五分钟长。天哪，他又回来了。对，我们需要做一个第二部分。我觉得我们只是勉强触及了表面。你本来会表现得好得多。我们太高兴了。我们本该邀请你的。我们本该邀请你参加那次旅行的。怎么回事？怎么回事？你还记得发生什么了吗？那次拍摄怎么了？大人物。不，你放了那么多名气。真是个混蛋。我不在乎。不，不。我知道。我懂。你知道的，比你们所有人都更有名。我知道。那是真的。我们在干嘛？不。你知道，这很酷。威特，你在干嘛？不。
Oh, no. Okay, sorry. Not today. Not today. Okay. Not today. But not today. Gladiator.
哦，不。好吧，抱歉。今天不行。今天不行。好吧。今天不行。但是今天不行。角斗士。
Gladiator. I don't even know her. Such a lesbian. It's so crazy. That way, he sports. So I don't know how that works. All right. I love Gladiator.
角斗士。我甚至不认识她。真是个女同。太疯狂了。就那样，他喜欢运动。所以我不知道这怎么运作。好了。我爱《角斗士》。
Hurry down to LA for some snacks and giggles. I will. And Sean, I'm coming to New York. I'm to LA for some snacks. I will. And Sean, I'm coming to New York. I'm coming to New York with my oldest son. Don't miss the play. Get there before the play. I'm going to the play. I'm going to see Alex Adelman next week.
快来洛杉矶吃点小吃，开心开心。我会的。还有肖恩，我要去纽约了。我要去洛杉矶吃点小吃。我会的。还有肖恩，我要去纽约了。我要带我大儿子去纽约。别错过那出戏。在戏开演前赶到那儿。我要去看戏。我下周要去看亚历克斯·阿德尔曼。
And then I'll literally, literally, the theater next to me. I will come see you the week after. Okay. Okay. I know that. I try to get him on the podcast to talk about it, but he was too busy, it was too tired.
然后我literally，literally，就在我隔壁的剧院。我一周后去看你。好吧。好吧。我知道的。我试图请他上播客聊聊，但他太忙了，太累了。
Who made it? Very tired. I see his wrist. I love your show. Not from the show, just recovering from the carbs. And I don't say I took credits. Sean pulled me aside and Provincetown and said, should I do podcast and I gave him a primer on the whole.
谁做的？非常累。我看到他的手腕了。我喜欢你的节目。不是从节目里看出来的，只是在从碳水化合物中恢复。而且我没说我居功至伟。肖恩在普罗温斯顿把我拉到一边说，我该做播客吗，我给他做了一次全面的入门指导。
Yeah, well, with the first time you interviewed me years and years ago and yours, I was like, how do you do this? Like, when you do it still long ago. You guys have done a great job. And I really appreciate it. Were you guys, you guys were in P-town? Just to, what, just trying to hit the cliché in the bullseye?
对，好吧，多年前你第一次采访我的时候，我就想，你怎么做到的？就像，你这么久以前就开始做了。你们俩做得真棒。我真的很感激。你们俩，你们俩当时在P镇（普罗温斯顿）？只是为了，什么，试图击中刻板印象的红心？
Yeah, we were doing gay things. What do you got? Checkshoes. Cheeshoes. Meaningless sex. Poppers. You guys going to poppers? Poppers.
对，我们在做同性恋做的事。你有什么？检查鞋子。臭鞋。无意义的性爱。POPPERS（亚硝酸异戊酯）。你们俩要去玩poppers吗？Poppers。
Yeah. Poppers. I missed, I missed took you for a game and you missed took me for a lesbian. Yeah, we made out for just a free second. It was magical. It was. You guys are freaks.
对。Poppers。我把你误认成了同性恋，你把我误认成了女同。对，我们仅仅亲热了一秒钟。太神奇了。确实。你们这群怪胎。
We were on a drag show. We were on a drag show. All right. We love you. Goodbye. All right. Thank you. Will you text me the video of the car?
我们在一个变装秀上。我们在一个变装秀上。好了。我们爱你。再见。好了。谢谢。你能把汽车的视频发短信给我吗？
I shall. It's really fun. I'll do it. All right. I love you. Goodbye. Bye. Thanks everybody. Thank you, thank you, thank you. That's a great guest. I love her.
我会的。真的很有趣。我会的。好了。我爱你。再见。拜拜。谢谢大家。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。真是个很棒的嘉宾。我爱她。
It's just a great guest. Really great. Couldn't you just literally, like you said, Jay, just have dinner with her and talk about everything? Well, yeah. How does one person have all that info? I could do a whole hour without you guys. It's just asking questions and questions and questions or three hours.
真是个超级棒的嘉宾。真的太棒了。你难道不能就像你说的，杰， literalmente，就跟她吃个晚饭然后聊聊所有事吗？哦，对。一个人怎么能掌握那么多信息？我可以不用你们俩自己聊整整一个小时。就是不停地提问，一个接一个的问题，或者三个小时。
I know. That's what I told you at the top. I was like, I don't read stuff or go on the internet. I just call her a texture. I'm like, what's happening with this? Yeah. I gotta say, how many podcasts does she have? She's got two right now.
我知道。我在开头就对你这么说过。我当时就说，我不看那些东西，也不上网。我只是打电话给她或者发短信。我就问，这事现在什么情况了？对啊。我得说，她到底有多少个播客？她现在有两个。
I should start listening to at least one. On with Kara and Pivot. Pivot. Well, and one covers attack and the other one covers journalism? Something like that. I was a guest co-host on Pivot, and it was really fun. You would be kind of know. You might want to know.
我应该开始听至少一个。《On with Kara》和《Pivot》。Pivot。嗯，一个谈科技，另一个谈新闻？差不多吧。我是Pivot的客座联合主持人，真的很好玩。你可能会懂。你可能会想知道。
You know the. Yeah, but I want to get some, I want to increase my, my, my carousel, I'm a person around podcast. Yeah. You know what else is interesting? Oh, here he goes. Hey guys, here goes.
你知道的。对，但我想增加一些，我想增加我的，我的，我的旋转木马，我周围都是播客的人。对。你知道还有什么有趣的吗？哦，他来了。嘿，伙计们，他来了。
Just, sorry, just clear. He ordered the deck. Sean's got a nice audience. Sean Hays is now in the middle of he thinks he might have started a buy. So you know, when we start following each other, I guess the door's waiting. I love it. Straight up. And then sometimes in the end, I wave. Good bye. Not as not as best. No, not as good. No, not as good. Not as good as the shark head. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no It was so crowded, so I yelled to the crowd, you can kiss my ass. Goodbye. No, no, no, no. You know, you know, listen, I'm gonna grab hold of the stick and I'm in the pilot seat, and I'm gonna spin around.
抱歉，只是澄清一下。他点了一份肉。肖恩有很多不错的听众。肖恩·海斯现在正处于他觉得他可能发起了一场买入的阶段。所以你知道的，当我们开始互相关注时，我猜门正在等待。我喜欢。直截了当。有时在最后，我挥手。再见。不是最好的。不，不是最好的。不，没有那个鲨鱼头好。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，库里人太多了，所以我对人群大喊，你可以亲吻我的屁股。再见。不，不，不，不。你知道，你知道，听着，我要抓住操纵杆，我坐在驾驶座上，然后我要旋转起来。
It's great to have a car with you. You know, when I wanted to get into her, I wanted to understand, you know. What's that, Will? Well, just, you know, just about the power of computing and what it takes, like for like AI, like is it, are we talking giga, mega, or kill a bite? Bye!
能和卡拉在一起真是太棒了。你知道，当我想要深入了解她时，我想了解，你知道。那是什麽，威尔？嗯，只是，你知道，关于计算能力以及它需要什么，比如像人工智能，比如，我们是在谈论千兆字节、兆字节还是千字节？再见！
Nice! You guys are better here the best. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
太棒了！你们在这里是最好的。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartness is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Granterry. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen Smart, less. Every big moment starts with a big dream. But what happens when that big dream turns out to be a big flop. From Wondry and Atwell Media, I'm Misha Brown and this is the big flop. Every week, comedians join me to chronicle the biggest flugs,
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。智慧是由Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael Granterry 100%有机且手工打造的。我们的下一期节目将在下周发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你都可以收听Smartless。每一个伟大的时刻都始于一个伟大的梦想。但当那个伟大的梦想变成一场彻底的惨败时会发生什么呢？来自Wondery和Atwell Media，我是Misha Brown，这里是The Big Flop。每周，喜剧演员们都会和我一起记录史上最大的惨败、
fails, and blunders of all time like Quibi. It's kind of like when you give yourself your own nickname and you try to like get other people to do it. And the 2019 movie adaptation of Cats. Like if I'm watching the dancing and I'm noticing the feet aren't touching the ground, there's something wrong with the movie. Find out what happens when massive hype turns into
失误和笨拙之举，比如Quibi。这有点像当你给自己起了一个绰号，然后试图让其他人也这么叫。以及2019年的电影版《猫》。就像如果我在看舞蹈时注意到脚没有着地，那说明这部电影出问题了。了解当巨大的炒作变成
major fiasco. Enjoy the Big Flop on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to the Big Flop early the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to the Big Flop early and ad-free on Wondery Plus. Get started with your free trial at Wondery.com slash plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
重大的惨败时会发生什么。在Wondery应用程序或您获取播客的任何地方享受The Big Flop。您可以在Wondery应用程序或您获取播客的任何地方提前且无广告地收听The Big Flop。在Wondery.com/plus上注册您的免费试用版即可开始。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。